today was one of the craziest days in
the in the trial of Kyle Rittenhouse and
I didn't think it could it could get any
crazier when the state brought in Gage
gross kreutz who testified that he was
only fired upon when he pointed a weapon
at Kyle Rittenhouse I thought it was
just this is Two Nuts today there was a
the defense filed a motion for a
mistrial with prejudice meaning that the
prosecution has committed misconduct or
error to such a degree there can't be a
fair trial and because of this they
should not be allowed to retry Kyle
Rittenhouse the judge actually said I
will take the motion under advisement
yelled at the prosecutor on more than
one occasions legit literally yelled at
him and said if one more thing happens
so here's here's what we might see we
probably won't but there's people
speculating about a directed verdict in
which the judge could just say as a
matter of law Kyle right now is not
guilty I'm not convinced that'll happen
but hey I'm not a lawyer I have no idea
the other thing that could that could
happen is that the defense could come in
in the morning with a full motion filed
for a mistrial with prejudice and this
was over specifically the the
prosecutors bringing up evidence the
judge had ruled would not be allowed and
the prosecution questioned Kyle
Rittenhouse because of his right to
remain silent it was such an egregious
violation the judge called it a grave
constitutional violation and actually
yelled the prosecutor saying it's a
matter I mean he's yelling a matter of
basic law for 50 years
crazy we gotta talk about all this we
also have Annika sparing of The Young
Turks admitting she was wrong much
respect to Anna for that because if we
we just need people to watch the trial
to understand we got the breakdown from
The New York Times over all their bullet
points I imagine will be arguing with
them because the media has been it's all
been malpractice in the media as we can
expect and then we got Jimmy Kimmel
saying that Kamala Harris is
historically low uh approval rating is
due to racism and sexism go figure and
we got some information about Alec
Baldwin apparently on set one witness
says the scene did not call for him to
draw a weapon and and point it at
anybody so there's a lot of questions
about that we'll get into of course
we're hanging out with Mr Jack Murphy
good to be back guys I missed last time
but I'm happy to be here happy to see
everybody's doing well Luke I'm even
happy to see you wow thank you I'm Jack
you can find me at Jack Murphy live or
come to Jack brunch jackbrunch.com we
just had an awesome Event in Austin
anybody I know going awesome
line on Saturdays at 5 30 a.m We got to
get up fantastic Austin beautiful town
we had almost 90 people out at brunch it
was a great time we're going to be in
San Francisco area not in that liberal
hellhole vax mandate nope we're going
across the river or the bay to Sausalito
no I was just thinking about sausage so
come on down jackbrunch.com very nice
Jack where's your 10-piece suit 10 PC
you know I like to dress it up for us
and I'm kind of disappointed well I
wanted to match you and your what should
we call this your casual wear well today
I am wearing another we are change
exclusive t-shirt
um pretty much depicting the weapons
used in World War One World War II and
currently our World War III or as some
people are saying fourth or fifth
generational Warfare and it's a shirt
that you could get exclusively on the
best politicalshirts.com and because you
do I'm here so thanks for having me it's
a camera loaded with cash
that's pretty much the modern day
machine gun dude an hour ago I was
taking a shower thinking about Sausalito
thinking if you're ever gonna go to San
Francisco just go to Sausalito and get a
view of San Francisco across the bay
that's awesome you guys are having Jack
brunch there Jack brunch.com come on
down yeah and you should come you know
when you should come you should come to
the one in DC on February 27th as long
as that works with our schedule because
we'll be traveling a lot the next couple
months next six months but I'm 100 if
we're in town I'm going to that oh
goodness I am excited at the prospect of
this brunch I do like Luke's shirt
that's very thought-provoking and I
wanted to say that I hope that you guys
are all keeping the witnesses for this
trial in your thoughts uh as we know
people who are going on the stand and it
is very stressful so keep them in your
thoughts and prayers all right I think
no you guys keep talking because I'm
trying to pull up the what do we pull up
over there I talk about snakes and frogs
I think it is really remarkable that
guys that we know people we talk to
people we hang out with our colleagues
and friends are in the middle of this
amazing trial which is having such an
impact and could have even more of
impact not only on Kyle's life but uh on
the nation at large I was listening to
Crowder earlier today and he's 100 right
when he talks about how this trial could
be any one of us it could be any
conservative anybody who decided that
they needed to try to defend themselves
which is terrifying I'm genuinely
concerned about what happens with this
case so I'm excited to get into it you
know I do Wonder like how nationally
prevalent is the case like I asked my
kids about it and they're like yeah
we're not even I'm talking about it in
school or anything but you would think
it's it's a guy who felt like he needed
to protect and defend his City or like
one of his like Hometown cities like
that's a that's what a very American I
found I found the email so we'll get
into all this oh there we go we killed
the time good kill the time thanks
everybody yeah I had the wrong email
pulled up but because we have a sponsor
today and it's a sponsor you know and
love is bio trusts MCT uh C8 MCT keto
Elevate powder my friends uh my uh my
friends go to eat write and feelwell.com
and you can get this C8 MCT powder if
you're doing keto or you want to cut
back on sugar this this is the stuff you
want it's all the good stuff it's medium
chain triglyceride some of the best
stuff in terms of getting your energy
levels up if you go to eat right and
feelwell.com you get 51 off and you will
also get a 60-day money-back guarantee
keto Elevate provides your body only C8
the most ketogenic MCT that means it
provides support for energy levels
healthy appetite Management Mental
Clarity and focus athletic performance I
will also add that I've now been doing
it for it's like it's like going on two
and a half three months I've been doing
keto and I put the stuff in my coffee it
feels great I had a period where I had
coveted and I didn't eat for several
days and this stuff is fantastic because
it gives you the energy it's probably
helping me keep me alive when I wasn't
eating because I was struggling with it
but uh you will get five grams of the
highly sought after mctc8 per scoop keto
Elevate is my favorite MCT powder on the
market today that's a fact and you get
free shipping on every order for every
order today bio trust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kidhungry.org to date BioTrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
Hungry kids please help them Reach their
goal of 6 million meals this year you
get free VIP live health and fitness
coaching from BioTrust team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order that alone is worth it
and their free e-report the top 14
ketogenic foods with every order again
eat right and feelwell.com
big fans of BioTrust any company that's
willing to support our work in these
tumultuous times when you got crazy
cancel culture stuff is a company y'all
should be supporting don't forget go to
timcast.com become a member of a members
only segment coming up around 11 or so
p.m and you can go to the store I'm
actually bummed about this YouTube
hasn't approved yet our shirt step on
snack and find out and there's a cute
little angry snake and it's not approved
on YouTube it's up on the store you can
buy it it's it's it's a funny little
shirt hopefully soon we can put it on
YouTube but until then smash the like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends I am I am
this story has has lit me up Jack was
just mentioning that like my segment at
four I was going crazy I'm like I'm like
yelling in the camera check this out
from timcast.com prosecution reprimanded
by judge for quote grave constitutional
violation during cross-examination of
Rittenhouse judge Schroeder also dressed
down the prosecution for attempting to
bring in evidence that he banned from
admission this is where it gets crazy
in the trial I'll give you the gist real
quick the prosecution said evidence that
occurred uh you call it evidence I don't
know an event that occurred four months
after the night in question is not
admissible because it has nothing to do
with him defending himself and so
they're like okay
the prosecutors started bringing it up
anyway and the judge got mad and we got
pissed but the craziest moment was when
the prosecution asked Kyle Rittenhouse
why haven't you told this story before
until tonight and then he says you
waited until everyone testified so you
could tailor your testimony and then it
was boom objection the judge goes off
he's like what do you think you're doing
you can't you can't do this you can't
question someone as to their to their
right to remain silent you know this
you're he's like you're an experienced
trial uh prosecutor
when the second violation came up he
snapped he's like I can't believe I was
astonished that you would dare bring up
something like that is a matter of basic
Law Firm 40 50 years and then the
prosecutors like you know when it came
to the question of the evidence he was
bringing in the prosecutors like you
open the door you're on her and he's
like for me not for you don't you get
Brazen with me I was shocked and here's
where it gets really crazy the I didn't
I didn't think it was going to happen
the defense said that if this persisted
they would file a motion for a mistrial
with prejudice meaning that the
prosecutors aired or or attempted to
break the rules to Prejudice the jury
against Rittenhouse to such a degree he
would never have a fair trial and that
the judge would have to uh dismiss
dismiss with prejudice meaning they
could never file these same charges
again
surprisingly they when when they put uh
Kyle in the stand he ends he starts
crying he's breaking down when they come
back the craziest thing the defense
actually files the motion asking a judge
for a mistrial with prejudice the ju
this is when the judge starts getting
into with the prosecutor he says I will
take the motion under advisement and
then essentially says if there's one
more violation to the prosecutor so
people are speculating now saying what
might happen is that the judge and the
judges actually said this he uh
something of this effect he doesn't want
there to be a circumstance in which he
intervenes and shuts down the court
proceedings he wants the jury to be able
to come to their findings but there's
speculation and I don't know how
valuable the speculation is that there
could be a directed verdict meaning that
as a matter of law the charges against
Kyle Rittenhouse are impossible to to
get when you had Kyle Rittenhouse
according to to uh the state's Witnesses
himself and everyone is he was yelling
friendly and fleeing the scene you can't
get intentional homicide on that but the
judge didn't rule it and people are
saying maybe he wants to see if the jury
will rule correctly he might intervene
after the fact so you can tell him
really amped about this totally yeah I
thought I was listening to your your
segment on 2x on the way up here man you
were you were hyped you know one of the
things I keep thinking about and I've
seen some other people ask about it is
this court case is being televised and
it's clear that that the judge is at
least neutral if not you know I don't
know he seems he's at least neutral
right he's not biased he's not clearly
got a left-wing bias how many times
Across the Nation over and over and over
again are prosecutors doing these things
that are unconstitutional and getting
away with it and even just having the
judge basically on their side as a way
to put people away that they think are
political uh you know sort of on the
other side of the political Spectrum I'm
sure from what I've heard from Julie
Kelly and other people covering the
January 6th stuff that uh if the judge
this judge here the writtenhouse judge
was there in in DC or wherever they're
trying these January 6th of that it
would be going a lot differently oh yeah
it brings up you know the idea of like
maybe every single court case should be
televised so that we can see every
single thing that's going on so that
these people can be watched it's kind of
scary to me to think that people that
guy an experienced prosecutor who
clearly knows about the Constitution
I've read from other lawyers that this
is a subject that comes up a couple of
times in law school plus it's on the bar
exam you can't you can't bring up the
fact or use it against them that the guy
didn't speak after his arrest and yet
Dairy did just as the judge said
brazenly yep violating this guy's
constitutional rights in the letter and
in the spirit of the whole thing how
often is this happening all across the
country this this is a prosecutor who
knows he has the the mob the rioters and
the Press on his side huh and even after
all of these grave constitutional
violations that's what the judge said
the media doesn't cover it the media the
media uh just says like Kyle written
they frame everything to the worst
degree for Kyle Kyle cries on the stand
because he probably killed the guys is
the headline The Daily Beast said Kyle
retinos makes wild accusations about
those uh claiming they were threatening
him and I'm like wild accusations
there's multiple Witnesses saying that
that Rosenbaum said if I get you alone
I'll effing kill you that was that was
this yeah the state's own witness saying
he drew his gun on Kyle Rittenhouse and
the daily beasts lie false frame I'll
say they falsely frame look I wasn't
there obviously I wasn't there but that
was one night that I watched as many
streams as I possibly could I watched BG
I watched Richie I watched one guy even
aggregate like three or four streams
into one so like I was there when uh
that guy became the n-word guy remember
like not there but like I was watching
at the gas station oh yeah Rosenbaum
yeah when rosenba became we were just
calling him the n-word guy because we
didn't know who he was because he was
running around screaming the n-word he
was obviously agitating he was looking
for conflict I'm going to get you I'm
gonna do this and like the people in the
press and and popular interpretation
just did not experience that the way
that the guy's on the ground obviously
did that writtenhouse obviously did and
then those of us who were watching it
intently actually experienced it that
night yeah framing is everything because
you could take certain facts and you
could emit some of them you could
highlight some of them and you know
there's different stories being told but
the fact that this case is being live
streamed I think is absolutely amazing I
think we should live stream all of
criminal court cases just so we could
actually get uh an unbiased point of
view to what's actually happening here
but it was kind of wild seeing the state
prosecutor literally argue more with the
judge interrupt the judge more than he
did the defense I was like what's is
going on here there was a number of
times the judge snapped on the state
prosecutor who looked like he was a deer
in headlights for many of the
proceedings so again the mainstream
media attacking Kyle is nothing new
they've been attacking him from the very
beginning we didn't even know a lot of
the details here the mainstream media
came out with a lot of spin on this
story and highlighted specific events
that fit their narrative now there's
another narrative there's you know talk
about some of these people who who were
shot their criminal past their criminal
history people are just selecting and
picking whatever fits their narrative
but truly seeing this live raw unedited
I think is extremely important and I
think we should normalize this as much
as we can yeah I mean aside from being
on the ground I watched it live from
multiple streams I've interviewed Richie
and BG on the scene I was just listening
to the podcast that we did with them uh
back in the summertime uh it's one of
these things where like I I have such
almost firsthand experience in this you
know I wasn't there but like to see the
discrepancy between what happened that
night talking to eyewitnesses watching
the trial out and then seeing what's
happening in the headlines like how
where did they even get the white
supremacists
they didn't kill anybody with black yeah
they're they're all tweeting that Cal
Rittenhouse killed three black people
what right like okay hold on hold on not
everyone but there's some elements on
Twitter and social people on Twitter I'm
pushing this and they're not getting
fact checked at all there was a a a New
York lawyer account with like quarter
million followers who tweeted I have not
been following this in my new detail but
I think the fact remains Kyle
Rittenhouse crossed state lines of an
assault rifle to go to a protest and I'm
like
the prosecutor has charges against
Dominic black for supplying a weapon in
Wisconsin to Kyle Rittenhouse that's a
substantial portion of the criminal
proceedings out of Kenosha these people
don't even understand what the
prosecutor is going for in this they
just made something up they all tweet
about it they don't fact check they
don't watch the trial and then they
claim they did I've been sitting here
every morning with it on livestream on
TV and then just like reading all the
legal analysis from like rakato law and
from Andrew branca and a plethora of
other uh you know legal analyzes
watching all these live streams and I'm
not going to pretend to be a lawyer and
no right all of the the Nitty Gritty
details and the law the defense is
citing various laws that were violated
by the prosecutor I can just tell you
the judge screamed at the prosecutor for
for a grave constitutional violation he
said he was like you're on the
borderline you may be over it I was
actually he cut himself off too he's
like and then I'll just I'll just leave
it at that for right now you want to
know why I was pissed I was listening to
ricada's stream and it was fantastic it
had 70 000 viewers on his stream it's
really really almost like Tim cast oh
yeah
I've been in this past year I mean and
so their commentary is fantastic I don't
know who it was but they made the
comment that the judge does it doesn't
he wants to prove that these trials can
happen that the process can work and as
soon as I heard that I realized if the
judge does not declare a mistrial with
prejudice he proves that prosecution can
violate your constitutional rights
Prejudice the jury by admitting evidence
that was deemed in admissible and the
judge will allow it to happen but if he
has this dueling incentive of a wanting
the jury to rule on the facts and
perhaps come back with a not guilty
verdict at the same time as wanting to
protect his constitutional rights and
the in the process and such and maybe
then go to this direct verdict that's a
that's a tough one for the judge to
actually manage isn't it it is it is but
I think some people have speculated that
the judge will wait for the jury to
issue their finding and then interview
can you imagine it happens but I mean
can you imagine if they come back and
say guilty on Ultra on all charges and
the judge is like
the reaction is going to be absolutely
that would probably be the worst case
scenario and then I mean the Chicago
Police Department already put out a
notice saying uh for officers that their
leave is not
um going to be uh approved because they
want all officers on the force because
they're expecting civil unrest to happen
in uh major cities so already there's a
lot of threats there's a lot of
hyperbolic language on on social media
that's not getting fact checked that's
not getting corrected that's being
escalated that's being promoted uh so
this is building up to another recipe of
disaster especially with the mainstream
media putting fuel on the fire in this
entire situation blatantly lying about
it there's a there's another address
that right yeah dude you mentioned the
rock in the hard place of the judge I
thought about that I'm like if he
intervenes people will claim there is no
fair trial but if we watch prosecutorial
misconduct malicious prosecution when
you there what was the guy's name de
Bruin I think his name was do you see
this the witness who testified that ADA
Krause and Binger brought him in and
told him to change his police statement
malicious prosecution that was on
zaminski I think his name is mizaminsky
Joshua not on writtenhouse but these
guys are clearly corrupt if the judge
says I'm going to allow this corruption
to play through then then
unfortunately the system is broken
maybe this isn't the A-Team either I
mean if you if you grow up in your
biggest goal in life is to become the
prosecutor in Kenosha Wisconsin does
that mean that you're that you're the 18
prosecutor no offense to Kenosha or
small towns around the country or
anything but maybe maybe this is just
standard you know incompetence that we
see and I mean I have no idea I haven't
sat in on too many murder trials in fact
the one that stands out to me is is OJ
this is all reminding me a little bit of
the OJ trial I was in college you guys
are probably too young for this but I
remember the whole country was watching
man and in fact like the I remember I
was a class at University it just
stopped the day of the verdict and like
it was such a big deal we were all
watching it I don't think that this has
that same level of national prominence
but just along among politicos oh yeah
definitely People Like Us let me let me
bring up this mainstream Media stuff
because someone actually just chatted
this and I had a so I had the New York
Times pulled up I want to go through
what the media's been saying but this
CNN article is one of the most egregious
violations of the truth
CNN writes Kyle Rittenhouse testifies he
knew Joseph Rosenbaum was unarmed when
he fatally shot him that is completely
immaterial
it was a a small second of this massive
trial and this is what the media does
they they pull Snippets this is also an
interesting point though many people
thought it was crazy they put Kyle
Rittenhouse on the stand there were a
few points he made that could not have
been admitted as evidence unless he
testified and that's why people think
maybe maybe that's why they put him on
the stand one was that Rosenbaum had
threatened his life on two occasions and
that he knew that the zaminski guy was
armed and he testified he heard the
gunshot as he was running and turned
what this what the prosecutor is trying
to do is falsely frame as much as
possible now I noticed a lot of people
asking why the defense wasn't objecting
to the insane questions of of the
prosecutor
some have suggested the prosecutor's
line of questioning were so absurd it's
prejudicing the jury against him he kept
asking the same question over yes same
question like five times and every time
Kyle would answer him he'd say I'll ask
you again
when you were going he was doing things
like you wanted to kill those people and
Kyle goes I didn't want to kill anybody
and he goes I'll ask you again you went
out there because you wanted to kill
those people right and he goes I didn't
want to kill anybody he asked the
question again over and over again yeah
he was bringing up video games uh he was
trying to insulate that video games or
akin to killing people no he said don't
you play Call of Duty with your friend
Dominic black and he's like I mean maybe
sometimes and he goes and isn't the
point of that game to take these rifles
and kill people and then he was like
video games aren't real life and then he
started talking about AR-15s being
prominent in the video game and and Kyle
was like well there's a lot of other
Firearms there's pistols and shotguns in
there as well but he was like but AR-15s
are the most prominent ones and they're
like no shovels and a lot of people a
lot of people were saying that it was
almost as if the term and concept of an
AR-15 was on trial so it's how much it
was brought up so how much it was talked
about let me let me show you how how CNN
frames this this is not an opinion piece
this is CNN's factual news they say Kyle
Rittenhouse testified Wednesday that he
acted in self-defense when he fatally
shot a man who had thrown a plastic bag
at him and chased him last year in
Kenosha Wisconsin in what is likely to
be a the pivotal testimony of his
homicide trial quote I didn't do
anything wrong I defended myself he
testified but in cross-examination
Rittenhouse said that he knew the man
Joseph Rosenbaum was unarmed when he ran
at the teenager right now said he
pointed his rifle at Rosenbaum in an
attempt to deter him adding that he knew
pointing a rifle at someone is dangerous
false that was leading questions from
the prosecution the prosecution said did
you point your weapon at Rosenbaum well
yeah of course he did and you did that
because you wanted him to know you would
kill him and you meant business and then
Kyle of course like says I didn't want
to kill him he keeps getting acid asked
what what CNN is doing is they're taking
statements from the prosecution that
Kyle either passively agreed with or
said I guess and they're acting like he
himself said it quote he was chasing me
I was alone threatened to kill me
earlier that night I didn't want to have
to shoot him I pointed at him because he
kept running at me and I didn't want him
to chase me you see they choose they
select all of the worst possible quotes
from Rittenhouse he said that he feared
Rosenbaum who did not touch his body at
all that night would take his gun and
kill people omitting the fact that the
it was I believe it was the medical uh
forensics medical examiner who said
rosenbaum's hand was on the gun
and Kyle redness who said he grabbed my
gun the prosecution then said but he
didn't touch your body and Kyle was like
right and now CNN takes that to falsely
frame exactly what happened let me pull
up this New York Times real quick they
say key moments from Kyle rignazz's
testimony one of the things they say
Thomas Binger the lead prosecutor
pressed Mr Rittenhouse about why he
aimed a rifle at Joseph Rosenbaum who
had run toward him but was unarmed you
wanted him to get the message from you
that if you come any closer I'm going to
kill you that's why you pointed the gun
at him Mr Right Now said he did not want
to kill Mr Rosenbaum though he believed
Rosenbaum was trying to disarm him quote
if I would have let Mr Rosenbaum take my
firearm from me he would have used it
and killed me with it and probably
killed more people so respect to the New
York Times for putting that quote in
right at the top yeah that was important
New York Times Julie Bosman States gross
gross Cruz Crossroads a paramedic from
West Allis Milwaukee suburb was shot in
the arm by Rittenhouse she says that he
was holding a handgun pointed in the air
when RIT house shot him from a short
distance away so that was that was at uh
she tweeted that at I copied it at 5 15
PM then I tweeted at her you should
probably delete this and at 5 15 PM she
deleted it well good right but she try
to put it out there until she was fact
checked on it she wasn't actually doing
her job she was making things up until
the Tweet started to go viral and people
were like why are you lying there are
two stages to this we should absolutely
criticize people who are incompetent
which is a large portion of the Twitter
Roddy the progressives and the media
when she puts out a false statement like
that that's very serious so during the
prosecution during the trial
the prosecution wanted to bring up video
on an iPad and they wanted to pinch to
zoom and the defense objected saying
that Apple's iPad uses artificial
intelligence 3D enhancing logarithms to
change the image and I tweeted out that
was insane and stupid because like the
the image interpolation is a very simple
thing that when as you expand it a
program machine learning basically tries
to fill in gaps that are missing it's
not 3D it's not artificial intelligence
that's still and then people were like
Tim you're making fun of Boomers trying
to explain something and I was like okay
I'll delete it I'll delete it I have no
problem
um that people make mistakes and there's
a lot of journalists so you'll see a lot
of mistakes but we should absolutely
criticize if I said something wrong
people did and I said okay I'll accept
it when she puts out fake information
she'll accept it we should not we should
not tolerate it but we'll be nice about
when they do bad jobs well not won't
which they should not remain in those
positions if they're that bad but then
next degree is like CNN
falsely framing select cherry picking
quotes and manipulating The Narrative or
NPR claiming that gross kreutz testified
his hands were in the air when he was
shot when he when he testified to the
defense that it was only after he
pointed the gun at Rittenhouse that is
egregious when MSNBC put out a video
where they say gross groins testified
his hands were up then they show a clip
of something totally irrelevant that is
intentionally trying to manipulate
people that's the second level of that
Jeffrey uh tubin was also on CNN Jeffrey
tuben if you don't know who he is he's
the guy who spanked it to his co-workers
on zoom and he was on CNN and he
literally said uh quote Kyle is an idiot
uh which I I think is just I mean I mean
that's the type of level of commentary
you expect from CNN but still even when
when it happens it's still surprising to
to to see it as that blatantly out there
right in front of your face because
truly what they're doing is a huge
disservice and people who are paying
attention watching the trial or getting
a totally different perspective than
people who course they're just
editorializing and commenting about it
uh like tubing was I think Kyle had a
hard time on the stand he he answered a
lot of questions very very well so the
prosecution uh when the defense was was
uh uh exactly was was doing the direct
with with Kyle Rittenhouse Kyle of
course you know he's probably worked us
out with the defense answered the
questions he did a really good job he
explained you know why he was there what
his goals were when it came to
cross-examination with the prosecutor
the prosecutor was just badgering him
and badgering him and caught him up in a
few instances and now the New York Times
says Mr Right Now struggled to give
clear answers to questions about why he
brought his gun as he ran towards the
car lot with a fire extinguisher the
event that immediately preceded the
shooting of Mr Rosenbaum I'm watching
the testimony and he's and one of the
questions he asked was after the
protesters cleared away from this area
why did you walk directly in this
direction instead of going around them
and I'm like that's a question that can
only be asked in hindsight and Kyle
didn't have a good answer her because he
never thought about it and he's on the
spot and that's why it was a huge risk
to put him on the stand because that
question is garbage nonsensical he was
like why did you have your gun what were
you trying to be protect like he asked
him why were you looking for Ryan Belch
and Kyle was like because you're safer
in Paris safer from who
and it's just like Kyle didn't have good
answers for this but I think he's he's
an 18 he's 18. he's not experienced and
this is why it's a risk to put him on
the stand if he was sharper if he was
quicker you know he could have said
something like because there was rioters
and arsonists and people doing violence
all over the place because criminals
exist because when you go out on the
streets for any reason you're safer with
another person regardless of whether or
not there's a writer so many of these
questions strike me as being in the same
vein of why did you wear that mini skirt
out at night young lady so so one of the
issues was when he was asking Kyle like
why did you bring a gun it's like
because someone might attack me who I
don't know and and but Kyle actually had
a really good answer he said you brought
the gun you the prosecution said to Kyle
asked him why did you bring the gun and
Kyle says I thought I needed protection
and then he said protection from whom
and Kyle said something to the fact of I
didn't think I would need to use
protection and then the defense the
prosecutor goes I'm confused you said
you needed protection now you're saying
you didn't and Kyle very quickly and
very very on on point sharp said I
thought I needed to bring protection but
I didn't think I would need to use it
and that was really really good but when
you have a prosecutor who's asking the
same question 50 times right you now
give the media the opportunity to say he
couldn't answer as Kyle kept was was
like getting confused and saying I'm not
understanding I don't understand your
question one of the things Binger said
was that hollow point bullets when
they're fired into somebody explode and
Kyle's like what and the judge was like
what like what are you talking about it
seems like a Gish Gallop are you
familiar with the Gish Gala I have
literally never heard that in my life
it's a bait tactic where you throw as
much garbage at someone so that they
look like they can't answer the question
properly so instead of asking question
and debate like it's two plus two four
you go look two plus two equals five and
two plus two equals six and three minus
7 is 22 and you know it's 22 and now we
have 7 minus three is four and the
opponent goes oh oh wait wait what did
you say what and the goal is to make you
look confused to the audience or it's I
don't know are these common tactics
generally speaking when doing a uh
cross-examination of witness like this
or is this specific to this case because
they don't have a real case and they're
trying to use these psychological
tactics well I mean I think they're just
fishing they're they're trying to throw
out as much as they can to see what they
could get back I mean being
cross-examined like that for hours is
difficult it's it's not easy so I mean
just watching the case it really looked
like let's just let's just keep throwing
something at it let's see if we get
something back and you know if you're a
state prosecutor they're going to do
everything in their power they're going
to take as much much time as they want
to of course try to beat up the the
witness beat up the person being
questioned and and try to make try to
literally break them uh that that's a
tactic used by many people in
cross-examinations just keep berating
them keep beating them keep asking them
the questions to see maybe it's an
interrogation tactic too to keep asking
the same question but in different forms
sure and you start you start off by
asking I'm like something that you know
is an affirmative did you do that yes
did you walk over here yes you get them
in the habit of saying I have given
testimony under oath a number of times
depositions in court and whatnot and
with some lawyers you know in my mind I
know where they're going and I can
answer honestly and still sort of you
know screw with them and win the game
but I am not 18 years old I am not on
the stand fighting for my life I am not
being accused of murder that has got to
be an extraordinarily stressful service
there's actually there was an amazing
point where they freeze frame a moment
when he had when he when Gage
grosskroitz was attacking him they
freeze frame it and in the still
writtenhouse's gun is pointed forward
towards the legs of Gage grosskroits who
gross Croix I represent him whose hands
are up and then he's like he's not
pointing a weapon at you but you're
pointing a weapon at him and then Kai
right now says you've it's a freeze
frame I believe if you play the video
you'll see I'm actually lowering the
weapon and I was like wow like Kyle
actually did a pretty good job on the
stand however it's the it's the James
Bond technique if you ask a woman to in
you know to hook up 30 times this is
literally the James Bond jokes from
Family Guy ask the woman 30 times and
she says no when you finally says yes
James Bond looks at the camera and goes
30 no's and one yes means yes it's it's
it was it that's the James Bond joke but
the point is that's what abusers do they
know that they can ask you the question
20 times until you finally get confused
and say what they need and then they can
put that on the record and then go to
the jury and say remember when he
testified X it's like yeah if you ask
the same question and 50 times and
Confused him that's a tactic they don't
have a case the crazy thing I'll say it
again was when the defense actually
stated to the judge that the prosecutors
either have forgotten the rulings of the
judge or purposefully trying to trigger
a mistrial because they know they have
no case and they don't want this to go
before the jury the defense actually
said that to the judge Master now what
does it mean when they've can the judge
and we're not lawyers but can the Judge
receive emotion and not rule on it
so one of the things the judge said uh
they wrapped up uh about I think like um
Eastern Time 540 or so the judge was
actually contemplating bringing another
witness but he said
it's a little late you know why don't we
uh you know come back tomorrow first
thing in the morning we'll dismiss the
jury and he said to the defense I'll get
you my preliminary no no
I I won't promise that but we'll see
what happens so I think the judge is
going to uh um issue a ruling on the
motion yes but I'm not a lawyer I have
no idea I have no idea you're better off
you know listening to lawyer commentary
that's just what the judge said about a
preliminary ruling on it I'm crossing my
fingers and I hope we have this much
attention on the gallane Maxwell case
which is going to be starting in a
little bit so I'm like please please
let's keep this kind of judicial uh
attention on such important uh issues I
was thinking that she was actually
hooking up with a bunch of those people
that would come to the hepson's place
well there's a lot of very serious
allegations around her but I don't want
to deviate too much for this particular
case I gotta give a shout out I gotta
give a shout out we're sitting here
we're criticizing the media yes and
there's someone in the media who
deserves some respect and people are not
going to want to accept it but we're
we're we're
people of principle Anna kasparian of
The Young Turks check us out from the
daily wire quote I was wrong Young Turks
kasparian admits she bought into false
Written House narrative
mad respect 100 wow disagree with her
politics I think The Young Turks have
been very unfair to me I think they've
lied about me on more than one occasion
Jank uger screamed at me at politicon
for no reason when I've known the guy
for years and I politely asked him like
hey you guys put up a smear piece on
Dave Rubin but like my name's like in
the thumbnail in the middle and they
started yelling at me all of that aside
if you recognize that you're wrong and
you correct it I will give you the
respect you deserve because if we if we
still you know if someone comes out and
says you know I bought into this false
narrative on caught right now which is
what an Experian did and then we refuse
to accept their acknowledgment you only
encourage them to keep doing bad we tell
them thank you for for saying the right
thing with with respect and hopefully
they continue to do the right thing do
the research looking at these tweets
from people they keep saying crossing
state lines with a gun crossing state
lines with a gun they keep saying
assault rifle Assault Rifle
wrong these people have not done
any any Research into this at all
and if they do I'll give them the
respect they deserve well that's big
that she came out and corrected her
statement because if we remember I mean
the mainstream media especially MSNBC
they were calling Kyle a domestic
terrorist a mass murderer they were
using extremely hyper bottle hyperbolic
language in order to kind of inflame
this situation there's people trying to
make this about race and again this has
nothing to do with any of that but when
it comes to this kind of salacious
action someone actually saying hey I was
actually wrong here it is very big
because the mainstream media doubled
down tripled down and they're still
trying to ignore a lot of important
facts in this case they didn't know what
happened but they still were able to
declare definitely domestic terrorists
definitely a mass murderer again we're
still finding out all the details of the
case here and the picture portrayed here
is totally different I saw a really
funny tweet you know you know who I love
to shout out is Cameron Caskey because
you know he seemed like somebody who was
acting in good faith initially but he's
totally just lost any will to be honest
he tweeted something really funny he
tweeted how come all of something I'm
paraphrasing how come all of these
centrists are so much smarter than me
and I thought it was really funny
because he's you know he's being
sarcastic he's saying they're not but I
realized that's the attitude that many
of these establishment Democrat types
and leftists have where they don't
actually read the news they don't know
what they're talking about but they're
arrogant enough to get online and say
these things and they are tribalist
individuals who are willing to retweet
it because it makes them feel good
inside but when you come out and say
assault rifle when literally not a
single person in Kenosha had an assault
rifle not a single person
I'm not gonna play stupid semantic games
they meant long gun not assault rifle
but they but saying that is factually
and legally wrong and they don't bother
to do a Google search
a Google search five seconds to figure
out what an assault rifle is they don't
even do that they get verified they get
a million followers and they tweet I'm
smarter than you I prefer DuckDuckGo but
that's just the separate cover go ahead
uh well you know I was thinking that a
lot of these people's uh perceptions on
this are prejudiced from the actions
that Facebook and GoFundMe took very
early ons right right so if Facebook if
Facebook where Grandma shares pictures
of her cats tells me that Rittenhouse is
clearly guilty and you get suspended I
don't know remember the details but they
did ban and censor some elements about
this and GoFundMe definitely took down
his fundraiser well then it must be true
because Facebook is a benign entity
where my pictures of my grandkids are
getting likes from all of our cousins
social media took people down for
talking about facts of this case so
that's that's absolutely huge people
were prevented from having a discussion
what was going on here we only got
mainstream media dribble and assertions
and then everyone else everyone else
left talking about this this was scared
of being targeted and taken down there's
people demonetized there's people who
lost their channels there's people who
were eviscerated and deleted unpersoned
because they were discussing the facts
here there was a really good tweet from
the libertarian party I think it may
have been of New Hampshire I'm not sure
they uh this account highlighted two
tweets one was from a leftist who said
that Kyle Rittenhouse is a white
supremacist who was hunting down civil
rights protesters which is a lie and the
other tweet said based on the evidence
in this trial it's clear that Kyle was
acting in self-defense the self-defense
tweet got suspended and the white
supremacist tweet massive retweets oh
there's this guy Brooklyn dad defiant or
whatever he's got something like a
million million followers just
constantly railing on this constantly
telling people lie lie lie a million
followers verified on Twitter look at
Sean King dude right these people built
careers off intentionally misleading and
this is this has been the the mo of the
establishment for the past as I mean
maybe maybe for longer than we realize
but you get Russia gay they accuse Trump
of doing what they literally did the the
clintons and the Democrats had more ties
to Russia and the and this manipulation
in lies than Trump ever did and they put
up fake news and the media helped him
now you then you you get Sean King and
there was that time he falsely accused
that cop of abusing that woman or
whatever there's a video he put out
where he claimed proud boys had gone out
and done something that proud boys
weren't even involved in he just lies he
knows it and many leftists have called
him out he's still got a million plus
followers he gets hired at these
companies like the intercept and the
daily news or whatever he gets paid lots
of money then you get Brooklyn dad to
find it turns out he's being paid by
political operatives that was a big
expose I could be wrong about that but
it's my understanding at the very least
that he was being he was a paid
political operative and even leftist
criticized him for it you have a massive
propaganda machine pumping out lies
making money their grifters what do they
do
they know they have to accuse us to
deflect so they'll say when we pull up
video or we pull up news articles and
and challenge them and show you you know
what's going on in the trial the other
day we played the actual video from
MSNBC and then the trial to disprove
their lies they'll claim we're the ones
who are manipulating people when Brian
Selter tells people don't watch the
propaganda come to us when I think it
was Cuomo when he said you can't legally
you're not legally allowed to read
Wikileaks only we can right anyone who
tells you not to seek out information is
manipulating you because I'll tell you
this watch CNN see what they say read
the New York Times see what they say and
then watch Crowder watch David Pacman
watch The Young Turks and watch us try
and get as much as you can because then
you'll see through the lies what do they
tell you don't listen to the grifters
they're manipulating you man this is one
reason why you got to be in good shape
guys because you need stamina to
withstand this constant barrage of Lies
manipulation disinformation if you are
weak if you're physically weak if you're
mentally emotionally spiritually weak
you're just gonna fall victim you're
just gonna be led right off the cliff
away from the truth and into ways that
are going to end up harming you in the
long run if you follow all the the
mainstream narrative now I agree with
Tim on on some points here especially
when it comes to seeing what the larger
media landscape actually looks like but
remember after watching the mainstream
media remember to squeegee clean your
third eye and to try to decompress and
uh you know because seriously there's a
lot of like trauma-based mind control
and a lot of psychological tricks and
dirty tricks used by the mainstream
media it's absolutely just when you when
you watch it it's like watching another
reality it's like watching another world
and and truly you have to be very
careful of what they say because you
have to fact check everything and when
usually when you do even in things even
with basic things that you think are
common you're shocked and surprised by
simply trying to look at the evidence
yourself what they're saying and what
the actual truth of the reality is the
difference is so Stark that it's
difficult to accept sometimes and you
and you think to yourself nah that can't
be possibly right and you doubt your own
person they can't be lying that much
right and then when you think about what
we're just witnessing in real time right
now and then you just think about all
written history and then then it's just
like oh God when we had uh we had still
Steve Helton on the other day and when
we were showing the video of that guy on
MSNBC I don't know his name and he was
like Gage grosskroitz testified that his
hands were up when he was shot and then
I play I play the video where the
defense is like it wasn't until you
pointed the gun at Cal Rittenhouse that
he fired on you and he goes correct he
didn't believe it he was like no like
how could they just say that and I'm
like the videos published after after
the testimony the Articles even if even
if the article came out right before
that testimony and they rushed it they
haven't corrected it and he was just
like I can't believe they would outright
and overtly lie like that and I'm like I
can't I try I tried to tell somebody you
remember uh the Portland shooting uh
where the antifa guys uh shot the uh
that Jay afraid Jay Daniels yeah Aaron
Daniels Aaron Danielson and uh nickname
Jay right and I and there was a guy who
filmed it live who was just allegedly
strolling along the street and happened
to pick up the entire thing on video
right so I got in touch with the guy and
I interviewed him and I went through it
frame by frame by frame and asked him
all the questions and then I asked him
why he was going to the protest and he
says oh my daughter got me into going to
these things black lives matter and you
know I just want to support her I'm like
oh you're a family man yeah you believe
in family right you're a good dad you
like leading your family like having a
whole intact family yeah well did you
know that black lives matter is opposed
to the nuclear family that wants to
quote disrupt the norm around the
nuclear family he's like nah I'm like
hold on a second I pulled it up I showed
it to him he read it and his reaction
was
oh that just must be a typo
that just must be a mistake they did
delete them they took it down because it
was so egregious and outrageous but it
is true it's part of their platform it's
what they believe and a guy I put it
right in front of him on the website
everything and he still could not
believe that he was supporting an
organization that was against his whole
raison being a dad and leading a fan
drives me nuts when people say I can't
believe it when something happens
especially if you watch sports
announcers oh he caught the catch I
can't believe it like dude believe it it
happened stop telling yourself you can't
believe what's right in front of you I
think one of the one of the big problems
that we're seeing now especially with
the right is that they keep saying
things like why would someone want there
to be no justice you know they're like
the the people who are cheering for Kyle
Rittenhouse to go to prison are cheering
the destruction of our justice system
why would you want that and I'm just
like you'd think after this many years
you'd realize that Communists who scream
long live the revolution this this guy
Gage grosskrautz testified he did hold
up his best are you are you affiliated
though did you go to their things yes no
no did you speak it though he said are
you a member are you a member he said no
no but you spoke at their events yes so
you're Affiliated yes did you chant the
slogans did you raise your fist and say
long live the revolution yes what people
need to understand and that's what I was
trying to say to Steve the other day
when you assume that your political
rival holds the same moral framework and
world view as you you are wrong you're
making assumptions when these people say
long live the Revolution and then you
wonder why it is they're lying under
oath they do not respect our moral
framework they do not agree with our
moral framework they do not respect the
authority of the court and they believe
they have a right by any means necessary
to subvert and destroy the system I was
surprised when he actually admitted
bicep guy I don't like using their names
I call them the n-word guy and the bicep
guy skateboard guy uh he I was actually
surprised that he just straight up was
like yeah he didn't point the gun at me
until I pointed the gun to him he tried
to nine get it first but he admitted it
he had to though that was what was so
crazy about the testimony the defense
was like even so I still was surprised
but check it out the defense said to him
first you pointed your gun at Kyle
Rittenhouse and then he fired upon you
and gross courts goes no
and then he was like he pulls the video
up and he hands him a photo and goes
that's a photo what is it of and he's
like it's my bicep being vaporized and
he's like and your gun is pointed at the
defendant he's like yes and that's when
he shot you yes so it was only after you
Advanced on the defendant pointed your
gun at him then he fired on you and he
goes yes when you're showing the picture
to the jury what's the dude going to say
no he tried that yeah that's right yeah
true this guy has no allegiance of the
prosecutor the prosecutors already put
himself in a position where he can't
criminally charge him so he's like
that's on you I'm not gonna make myself
look worse and incriminate myself there
you go dang I don't understand that
that's like what's called perjury he
just lied to the jury under oath yep but
but this is a mat that the issue is
there's a big difference between like
hard perjury and an interpretation of
course so when he's like you know it
wasn't until you pointed the gun he's
like no and then well here's the video
oh yeah I guess so it's very different
from them and this dude lied a lot it
was funny when the prosecutor playing
the video with Gage grosskroitz holding
his gun and he goes so at this point
you've pulled your gun as you're
approaching Kyle Rittenhouse and he goes
no and then prosecutors like here's the
video we just played with a gun in your
hand and he goes yes I like this too is
lying the worst but perjury almost never
my understanding is almost never gets
prosecuted and it's typically for like
were you at the bar at 2AM no I was in
Buffalo New York and then they find a
picture of you there you'd overtly lied
about what you were doing and then they
might try because you knowingly spy on
the American people yeah
that's James Clapper by the way
committing perjury that's right and and
everything and unfortunately when him
and Schiff and all of these these
cronies went on TV and lied about Russia
gate they weren't under oath when they
were under oath in Congressional
testimony they admitted I have no
evidence it's not true it's all bunk
that's that's one of my favorite things
talking to cash and pointing all that
stuff out I'm so glad that he was on the
show what a good dude all right now
listen we just gave respect to Anna
kasparian because she corrected the
record on a mistake she made and now I'm
going to highlight Jank euger I'm not
I'm not someone who you know I typically
don't like talking about The Young Turks
or other commentators but this is
actually a really important and a
cultural moment that we're getting not
just from jankyuger but from one of his
followers that I think we absolutely
need to address
Jen kuger tweeted so Joe Rogan's show
has now become a boring right-wing show
no real diversity of opinion it's just
insane conspiracy theories and
right-wing lies like every other Alex
Jones and Tucker carlson-like show and
it's obvious he doesn't want to be
challenged on his ideas anymore
the Democrats just lost miserably in a
series of elections in Virginia notably
due to critical race Theory Suburban
Housewives white Suburban women voted
for the Republican critical race Theory
plays poorly with you know working-class
individuals and suburbanites
we saw a state senator who spent only
153 dollars
win without campaigning against the
incumbent Democrat who refused to
concede until today is like Okay I
accept that I lost because people just
said I'll take a ham sandwich if there's
an R next to it that's how much people
are fed up with the Democrats with
wokeness with all of the stuff we've
been complaining about for a long time
if you look at
basically every metric you'll see that
independent voters are leaning closer
towards Republicans simply because
Republicans are closer to them and
Democrats are going further and further
left Pew research put out a political
tribes chart there is there's a group
called The stressed sideline which is
the least politically active group
according to their Survey Center right
position the individuals who consider
themselves to be politically neutral are
center right we would probably fall
under what pure research refers to as
the ambivalent right they're not it's a
group of people who aren't conservative
but have voted Republican who are
actually fairly Progressive on certain
issues or economic issues but are
against the Democrats and wokeness and
all that stuff back to what genk yuger
is saying and here's why I think this is
so important to highlight not just
because of his comment but because of
one of his followers responses who said
I'm also feeling that way about e-cigar
and crystal ball with their breaking
points Joe I loved it when they
impartially went after both sides of MSM
but now it's just one-sided attacks and
conspiracy theory theories no balance
anymore
my response was as Democrats begin to
lose and moderates are shown to be
closer politically to the right because
the left has gone so far left a
breakdown among the left ensues
Jack huger's only responses because he's
built up his audience around chasing
this Fringe unpopular ideology is it's
not me who's wrong it's everyone else
who just voted against us and his
follower says that's right crystal ball
and cigar who are very like Crystal
Ball's Progressive yeah no no they're
far right now because they're telling
the truth yeah they're breaking down
yeah it's amazing I mean we've been
talking on this show for a long time
I've been talking about it that the CRT
in schools is going to be the biggest
red pill delivery service that we've
seen and it clearly played out that way
you know we've been talking about that
right pill deliveries about for two
years I mean when your daughter comes
home from school and wonders if she's a
racist because what they're talking
about in class you know that's going to
get Mom and bear activated and I also
just want to give some big shout outs to
some friends of ours Corey DeAngelis and
Christopher Ruffo boy James Lindsay
James Lindsay of course and you know but
all of us here have been hammering all
this stuff for a long time uh and uh
dude they they had a huge hand in what
happened in Virginia you know and it
really really shows and and thank
goodness because I love Virginia and I
want it to be red it really shows that
what we need is a it's a big network of
people that aren't necessarily on the
same campaigns and aren't necessarily
getting paid by the same people and
aren't necessarily totally aligned but
you need people you need the academics
to Define it you need the media people
to set the stage you need the campaign
managers to follow the lead and follow
the polls
and what happened to Virginia was
amazing I was in Orlando at the National
conservativism Conference the night that
young can won and Chris Ruffo was
sitting right next to me and when they
announced it oh man it was so exciting
because that dude has been busting his
ass but how crazy is it that here we are
you're Democrat to deplore well being
like I want Virginia to be red and I'm
at the conservatism conference I know I
know and it feels Perfectly Natural and
those people feel perfectly I mean I
definitely did not agree with everything
that I heard at the national
conservative concert however but they
did feel more like quote my people
and who would just interpret a random
event in a similar fashion then these
crazies like [ __ ] and dude like I'd I'd
gotten media game later than you so I
have no I have never seen this Jank
euger guy be reasonable or or say
anything smart or whatever he's just
been this buffoon you should go
screaming and yelling with some sort of
idiot 2007 he was pretty hard on George
Bush and the Iraq War he was a shining
Beacon speaking out against it it was
very nice he was criticizing a lot of
very powerful forces many multinational
corporations he got a contract on MSNBC
MSNBC tried to stifle him and shut him
up and he said no and he made it a huge
issue he actually stood up and got
gained a lot of respect from a lot of
people and then ever since then I think
he's just been going downhill and
drinking some very strange oddly
smelling Kool-Aid and has gone off the
deep end money and Views start warping
your mind too man they do this is what
happened to to all of these
establishment forces
um the Young Works they were big they
were leftists you have CNN who was
supposedly the corporate their corporate
media for sure but they were never hard
left the way they became what happened
was especially for The Young Turks is
that you go on Twitter and you look at
your mentions and you get 30 replies and
you're scrolling down and they're all
saying you are wrong about X people are
easily manipulated by this assuming that
30 angry people represent their entire
base so what happens is eventually The
Young Turks and other you know digital
Outlets start saying wow my followers
think this is right or they think this
is wrong I don't want to lose followers
so they started hearing to a fringe
minority we've seen the polling date
it's been eight between eight and ten
percent of the country if you want to
abandon ninety percent of the country
for eight percent because it's a market
share for you good luck what's happened
now is The Young Turks CNN MSNBC have
you seen this they're losing all their
talent Rachel maddow's canceling her
Daily Show she's gonna do a weekly show
and Brian Williams announced he's
leaving leaving because their ratings
are in the trash they have almost no key
demo but they're in the trash because of
her
no no well here's what happens if you
lie for years russiagate they dedicated
themselves to being wrong people are not
the stupid clowns they treat them out to
be there are some stupid clowns but
average people are average and average
people can see through lies they
understand that the square peg goes to
the square hole yeah so when they come
out and they say Trump blew with Russia
we know it for a fact Clapper goes on
her show and says we've all seen the
evidence and then three years later the
report comes out Trump didn't those
people go
the hell was I just watching and then
what happened their ratings collapse
Rachel Maddow was nearly in tears but
she can't give it up why she lost
moderates who are looking for real news
she retained the cult members The Young
Turks have done the same thing now Jank
huger's only option is to say Joe Rogan
who is moderate left-leaning and the
most popular podcaster and probably the
second most popular comedian is far a
right-wing boring show Jank Joe Rogan is
like your average dude talking about
like crazy things all the time he's not
a Tucker he's not Tucker Carlson he's
not a right-wing pundit when I look at
Joe Rogan I'm like that should be your
barometer for regular people right the
pulse of the nation look and and you
look at his shows when he goes and
performs people in New York show up for
him these are people in Democrats
strongholds with vaccines accepting the
mandates absolutely yeah and and so when
I you look at Joe Rogan and he is very
likely representing regular Americans
butt the Democrats have pulled you you
look at this the Pew data that got
released that went viral when it shows
the Democrat Shift versus the Republican
shift do you remember this yeah the
Democrat Center has not become far left
and the Republicans have moved like one
point to the right so Republicans are
closer to where they've always been what
happens to a moderate or someone like a
Joe Rogan they look to their left and
every day they lie they cheat they steal
and they get further left and they look
to their right and as a republican
saying the same thing they always did
and they're like the Republican says the
Fourth of July barbecue and Christmas
are great I like those things too they
look to their left and they're like
you're white you're racist Christmas is
racist shut up and they go okay that's
nuts right exactly you know this is why
if you're in journalism if you're in
media it's really important just to be
dedicated to the truth right because
then you just ask questions and then you
can be wrong because you were never like
I this is what I believe you just you're
just asking questions I'm just a guy
with the microphone I'm just pulling on
a thread I mean that's my whole stick I
don't know really the answers to
anything I'm just asking questions
trying to figure it out and go where the
answers take you but that takes that
takes being able to withstand your
audience being mad at you right and
because if you just respond to your
audience being mad at you like uh you
know I catch a lot of crap for being
anti-trump I catch a lot of crap for a
lot of things but it's it's those
moments where you need to have some
fortitude because that's when you're
staying true to just the pursuit of
truth and that's why guys like Mike's
[ __ ] get so much crap from people
because he's just trying he's just
pursuing the truth his version of the
truth whatever he's just asking
questions and he's trying to come to his
own understanding it's when Mad Al dude
I sat on November 7th Donald Trump lost
get over it you need to move on and all
the hardcore Trump supporters were like
you know Screw Temple they were mad at
me yeah but still the left claims I
pushed The Narrative of election fraud
which I never did right in fact Steve
Bannon came on the show and I I argued
with him about it saying I think you
know you guys are focused on the wrong
thing you got to focus on Democrats
ground game and how they did voting in
the park and how they did Universal mail
and voting because that is the edge that
got them the win
the left will still lie about me
so here's one of the challenges
um it was an example of the writtenhouse
case one of the challenges with
believing in America the judge his
ringtone was proud to be an American yes
what does that mean it means he'll be
biased for them he's gonna say it's not
good it means he's biased for the left
for the left for the left why do you say
that because he truly believes in the
justice system he's going to allow
prosecutorial misconduct because he
wants there to be a jury trial because
the jury trial is the American thing to
do so as the left the prosecutor lies
cheats and steals he'll say it is the
American value to give an equal
opportunity to everyone
you have people who raise their fists
and say long live the revolution their
explicit goal is to destroy this nation
and you are welcoming them to The Fray
and giving them an opportunity
I thought about this and this is what
you'll get a a leftist revolutionary
sect and Democratic establishment
authoritarians who will cheat and use
your good faith to continue doing it
definitely so my thought was kind of we
should only extend the values of our
justice system to those who uphold it
equally for us as well if we believe in
the Bill of Rights and the Fifth
Amendment Second Amendment why would we
give people an opportunity to take those
rights from us what I mean to say is if
we believe in the right to remain silent
in a fair trial and someone walks in and
says I will not give you that same
benefit but I demanded of you we should
respond with no either we all agree
these are the rules or we won't apply
them to you if you don't want them
simplified even further if you don't
believe in free speech why would I
defend your right to free speech you
don't believe in it I'll give you the
respect you've asked for
it's a tough fun man the issue is I mean
I hear what you're saying I hear what
you're saying but like the right to yeah
that's tough so but those are the most
egregious circumstances that Free Speech
has to be supported yeah is even for
people that don't believe in it right
even for people that are acting insane
for people that are doing the dumbest
craziest things that you could possibly
think of yeah then that's why guys like
Mark randazza are amazing because they
go out there and defend those kind of
people I agree but there's a line yeah
so I I there are a few been a few
pundits who have pointed out that one of
the problems with conservatives and the
more libertarian-minded people on free
speech is that they're unwilling to
accept any limitations on speech in
pursuit of free speech which is the
wrong thing to do well we need to
recognize that there are certain limits
culturally that we're not willing to
accept and then call out the left for
violating these same limits and not
respecting the free speech that they
demand
to put it simply there's that Paradox of
intolerance where they say if you
tolerate intolerance then the intolerant
win and that's not necessarily untrue we
all need to agree on the rules and then
operate within those rules if someone
seeks to destroy our rights and attack
our way of life we should not you know
uh give them you know equal opportunity
we should not open the door for them to
put it simply
wrap this all up my point is
the judge in the writtenhouse case knows
they're breaking the rules has yelled at
the prosecutors but it's still as
someone who believes in America an
American is proud will uphold these
systems which benefit those who lie
cheat and steal and are seeking to
destroy the very system that is
protecting them it is a paradox it just
means that we can't be absolute in our
defense of
um egregious actors we certainly will
protect their free speech and act in
good faith but when it becomes apparent
that they're trying to destroy the
system we say okay we can't tolerate
your attempt to destroy Free Speech do
you so that logic do the 911 suicide
bombers do they deserve a free like a
fair trial absolutely okay so uh
I think what I mean to say is uh and I
think you know Ian helped my
understanding of this he had some good
questions about the ethics of vaccine
lockdown of of mandates and lockdowns
when you brought up Ebola and what
people's rights are
there's a point where if there was an
Airborne Ebola everyone in this room
would be like lock it all down right
like an 80 mortality of people coughing
and their insides are liquefying and
you're watching it happen we'd all be
like lock it we'd be freaking out yeah
but to varying degrees so then you know
I started to think that for the most
part it's really about how much risk
you're how much you're willing to
tolerate in terms of sacrificing
freedoms because everybody's willing to
give up something if it if something is
you know give us some of their freedoms
if it's egregious enough I think for the
most part we just happen to be people
who watch the show on us substantially
more libertarian than they are so
they're more more likely uh to take away
people's rights we won't we won't
tolerate that but a really good point
that was made that I think helps will
help people understand this is that
someone said to Tucker Carlson you would
not allow someone to come on your show
and make racist comments and Tucker said
you are correct he's like right we agree
there are limits on acceptable speech
it's a good point the legal limits
should not be banning hate speech but
the culturally acceptable limits exist
in which case we need to enforce
culturally our ideals and tell people
who would say Revolution nothing less by
any means any means necessary that we
will not accept that that culture since
we're opening this can of worms let's
talk about this for just for just one
quick second I knew I know a guy and uh
his he separated from his wife and his
kids are in Israel
and his daughters Bob Mitzvah was coming
up
and it looks like that the judge is
going to actually order the kids to stay
in Israel
and so he and in Israel you can't enter
the country unless you have a vaccine
so what does that guy do the choice is
and he's just Mega opposed to the
vaccine uh his grandparents were you
know captured by the Nazis like he has a
history with this
forced medical procedures Etc he was
faced with get the vaccine and see his
kids or don't get the vaccine and maybe
never see his kids again
that is a extremely difficult situation
to be put in if you believe very if
you're very adamantly opposed to the
vaccines and the mandates
and I don't think any of us would argue
here that this guy should never see his
kids again right so what that clearly
lays out for us is that there is it is a
personal decision about this and it's a
spectrum and so I don't fault the guy
for getting the vaccine to go see his
kids it broke his heart like it tore him
up because he didn't want to do it
because he was opposed to it and he
hated it but they put him in a situation
where it was like see the kids or get
don't don't get the vaccine but that's
it that's how they win and that's this
is the big this is the Big Challenge the
logic of it is simple
go for someone's children and you will
have a Slave
they win as long as people there's no
escaping here there's that guy there's
multiple options there's multiple ways
of trying to go through the system uh
with the system not looking there's I
I'm not advocating for any illegal
activities but if there's a will there's
a way compliance isn't the easiest way
it's going to be the the easiest way for
the moment but in the long term it's
going to be the most difficult way for
everyone else including that person who
you know compromised his morals to
comply with the state so there's many
different ways around the difference you
should compromise one element of his
morals to honor the rest of his morals I
don't again I don't agree with that kind
of argument there's many different
avenues that people could walk down that
doesn't include compliance that could
still uh allow him to see his children
in many different ways in many different
Avenues and I think you should ex you
should explore all of those options
until there's not an option possible
flying to it went like fake vaccine
cards and things like this again I'm not
not here to Advocate any of that I think
advocating that is even a thing under
the FBI I mean there's human rights
legal proceedings he can get a lawyer he
could file lawsuits he could say I will
not you know the government can't
mandate a medical procedure and take my
kids from me meet in another country uh
have a mediator come in and say hey okay
let's go meet in Egypt or let's go meet
in Turkey let's go meet somewhere nearby
and establish that we're going to be
doing this in some sort of way that
doesn't that infringe on my value that
assumes that he is a Cooperative ex-wife
okay but but you know there's there's a
will there's but hold on you bring up an
ex-wife now we're talking about two
civil parties and a government entity so
it's much different from an individual
versus the government when there's a
civil case between two individuals sure
my point is is that it there's a
spectrum and it's hard and there's a
decision to be made at some point and
the fact that the decision exists is a
symptom of the problem uh not a
contributor to the problem it's actually
there there is something more simple if
everyone said no there wouldn't be a
problem the problem is that people bend
the knee
and that's it if you're the one if
you're the one percent left resisting
you you've got no one with you right and
that's why I've always been the kind of
person that says I would rather live an
abandoned by the river than compromise
and and you know the only way this is
ever going to end if is if people stop
complying you cannot comply your way out
of tyranny I said this a couple weeks
ago it's impossible it's impossible
because they're going to keep pushing it
more and more the NBA is mandated
boosters oh yeah the NBA has sold all
players coaches and referees that you
have to have a booster shot if you've
got the Johnson Johnson after two months
and any other and the Pfizer in modern
after six months obviously this was
coming we knew this was going to happen
and now the cdc's already said weeks ago
they may change the definition of fully
vaccinated of course they're going to
so it's only going to get worse and you
look at the inflation you look at the
food shortages you look at the price of
a turkey this year it's insane doubled
double they're calling it meat flation
that's happening right now not just
Bacon's up 20 so the people who said I
got I gotta prioritize feeding my kid
Congratulations by complying you have
taken the food out of their mouths
short-term gains for long-term
sacrifices sacrificing the future of
your children because it's easier now
you look you take a look at the at the
long hard Road and way off in the
distance you see paradise and you take a
look at the short trip over the bridge
and the bridge collapse and you end up
getting washed away sometimes you people
got to realize that life is not easy
life is not fair and takes hard work and
you have to you have to face the
challenges head on because when you take
the easy route
you make everything worse not always but
often predominantly especially it's
never easy it's never an easy it's
whenever you do something cheap uh I
think that's the way of describing this
it's going to come back and haunt you
and when more and more people comply I
mean people complied in Israel they just
said we'll do anything we'll go along
with the vaccine passports we'll get
vaccinated everything will be fine the
government said well well well no now
you need a booster shop now you need a
third shot now they're even talking
about a forged shot so with him
complying and saying yes I'll go buy
your rules I'll go buy the four fourth
shot's already official for
immunocompromised so but not mandated a
part of the official passport system
which they will be implementing very
soon and then the fifth shot and then
then we're talking about what hepatitis
shots or University of Denver has
already mandated flu shots yeah
compliance my favorite was the Yahoo
news story said NBA recommends boosters
for all you know referees and everything
and then later on it said if you don't
do it you'll be subject to all the same
restrictions blah blah so it's a mandate
there was a really cool guy from the NBA
at the national conservative
conservativism conference as a matter of
fact Isaac Judah Orlando Magic sixth
round or sixth pick overall this like
big time player right uh and he came and
sat on stage with Dave Rubin whoa yeah
dude NBA six foot eleven look look Isaac
Judah seeing people like Kyrie Irving
Aaron Rodgers people who are willing to
speak out and stand up for what they
believe in this is fantastic now Aaron
Rodgers apparently lied about his you
know immunization or whatever and I he
should have spoken up and just been true
and honest from the get-go but I think
when we start seeing celebrities and
athletes speak out in defense of
individual liberties individual rights
that's a good thing that's an amazing
thing and we need to encourage more of
it it was amazing to see him at the
conference and I'll admit I thought that
the crowd was just a little too excited
the fact that there was like an
African-American guy there wait wait
that's every conservative conference
these days
[Music]
I mean that's you know that's the vibe
right uh but that guy I've not been in a
conference like that that guy was super
well spoken very intelligent and uh made
his case very articulate yeah well the
media his uh natural immunity well the
media attacked him viciously because he
wasn't going along and and he did a
whole press conference where he
addressed this entire matter and brought
up points very eloquently and was
talking about all the scientific issues
that actually mattered that that I would
everyone was like I wish this guy was Dr
fauci because he explained scientific
terms in such an easy simple way that
that made a lot of people understand his
position and they stopped attacking him
because of the weight that he he
approached this situation without
getting angry without attacking without
yelling without freaking out and just
said okay here let me just explain
myself calmly rationally and because of
that they stopped attacking him he's
still playing
um something something yeah we've
brought up a lot there are a lot of
celebrities that watch this show they
message me definitely there's a lot of
famous athletes actors musicians
and unfortunately
they always say the same thing I won't
speak up right exactly and I'm like dude
you're who needs to speak up you got two
million followers right make a post look
at look at Demi Lovato she she became an
ambassador for Gaia and now they're
attacking her saying she's like it's a
conspiracy website and it's like it's a
yoga and like holistic health like Forum
or something they're just
anyone that tries to deviate from the
control of the corporate establishment
is smeared anybody here's a question for
you I don't know the answer did George
Washington pay the stamp tax
I don't know no idea if the answer is
yes then all this stuff we can just
throw this whole argument in the trash
because
he complies complied because he waited
until the right moment to make his move
anybody out there did George Washington
pay the stamp tax did Sam Adams pay the
T tax did they pay the tax on the T
before the tea party let's get this
answer because that could put this
question to bed yeah but Jack you're not
making any moves what do you mean well
the argument is like you just gotta
comply comply and then and then go
against 1965 dude or 1765 right give me
nine years let's see nine years
or 11 actually you know the big
differences though is that
communicating took months so if you took
11 years well if you were a rep in
Virginia communicating with New York
about revolutionary ideas sure it's a
couple weeks to send the letter sure but
but so the actual conversation could be
months unless you came down for a
special meeting in Philadelphia or
something I would love to know if any of
our founding fathers Thomas Jefferson
Hamilton if any of those guys paid the
stamp tax at any point in their life
because if they did let's talk about it
why don't we just Google it I just tried
it it didn't come up Jack you're just
trying to justify compliance I haven't I
haven't it's gonna work I haven't taken
the vaccine my kids haven't taken the
vaccine I don't know why everybody's
giving me a effing hard time about
having a conversation for people in
America that are struggling with this
issue well I am not vaccinated or buddy
well well Jack I appreciate the
conversation I think it's an important
one I'm happy we were able to have to
have that's why I wasn't here last week
two weeks ago when I got the call that
cast Castle was under you know attacked
by the coronavirus I was like I'm not
going because I don't have the vaccine
well to be fair we didn't know for sure
at the time time I know but Lydia was
like everybody's sick dude I'm sorry and
here's one of the problems with the
testing mandate is we had four tests to
be negative right and so we were like
tests cleared us we're good it's
probably a cold and then turns out you
know yeah so you know this a cursory
glance at the Stamp Act just mentions
that the the colonists viewed as a
violation of their rights uh they
protested it but as to whether or not
they were paying it
good question so you're saying that with
the Boston Tea Party they should have uh
you know complied and not done what I'm
what I'm saying is that what you're
saying what I'm saying is that there's a
matrix to make decisions as to whether
this action is going to have the desired
outcome or if it's only going to be
deleterious to yourself or harmful to
yourself uh there's a lot to consider
and not everybody even the most
venerated people in our history the
people you call Patriots the people that
founded this country I bet you they
didn't resist every single moment of
tyranny before they finally had had
enough and and actually like the things
that they revolted over in some cases
pale in comparison to things that we're
dealing with now but the point is is I
think that there is a matrix by which
you can make these decisions that's
probably different for each person and
it's just an interesting historical
question I have an answer for you what
uh Benjamin Franklin actually suggested
the appointment of John Hughes as the
agent for Pennsylvania to implement the
the stamp uh to be a stamp distributor
not aware of the turmoil that the tax
would create between American British
relations to simplify
when the when when the Act was
implemented people had to actually
engage with it before they understood it
was bad and then reject it so it seems
like what happened was the government
said we're implementing this a bunch of
political leaders were like okay and
then they started talking about it and
then over time because communication was
slower back then people started
protesting in the streets for like five
years they were protests over this so
once people were impacted by it
understood their ramifications they
started rejecting it but did they have
did they pay the stamp tax in the
meantime while they were uh while they
were protesting I think I think the fair
during the protests probably not
probably what happened was and again
this is speculation I know totally we
should get a history but what I can say
is initially they did pay it and what
likely happened is they gradually began
not paying it as the protests expanded
right so as opposition grew people said
I won't comply but that is to say that
means people who want the vaccines and
believe in the mandates of course will
comply yeah but that also means that
people who protest and oppose it would
not comply
yeah
interesting historical question I'd love
to dig deeper on that yeah you know what
I want to dig deep around I don't talk
about Alec Baldwin there we go let's do
it so uh we love subtle transitions I I
well so I mean look we're talking about
trials we're talking about Rittenhouse
we're talking about there's a bunch of
Trials actually the armored Aubry case
is going on we have more information on
the Alec Baldwin uh a case a rust crew
member this is the movie rust is the
name of the film where Alec Baldwin shot
and killed that woman he is suing Alec
Baldwin and the set armorer for severe
emotional distress overshooting
the independent is reporting fatal scene
did not require Baldwin to pull trigger
lawsuit claims
it's a claim of a lawsuit if somebody's
trying to make money so I don't know
that it's true a lot of people are
saying why would an electrician have you
know key details in that regard the
independent reports
a rust crew member who held the dying
Helena Hutchins in his arms has sued
Alec Baldwin armorer Hannah Gutierrez
Reid an assistant director Dave halls
for severe emotional distress over the
shooting had electrician Sergey svetnoy
alleged in the lawsuit that the scene in
which Miss Hutchins was killed did not
call for Mr Baldwin to fire the weapon
which she had been told was cold Mr
Baldwin is sued in both his capacity as
an actor and a producer of the western
movie which has been shut down as
investigations into the death continues
Mr savatnoy claims in the court papers
that the bullet that killed Mrs Hutchins
also struck director Joel soza almost
hit him as well according to TMZ he
states that he is suing Mr Baldwin
because the star owed a duty to the
plaintiff and other crew members and
actors on the rust set to handle the
cult revolver provided to him by
defendant halls with reasonable care and
diligence for the safety of the rust
cast and crew they're going to say quote
this Duty called for defendant Baldwin
to double check the cult revolver with
Halls upon being handled to ensure did
not contain live ammunition Court paper
State the lawsuit also claims the Fatal
scene did not require Baldwin to pull
the gun's trigger with the script
instructing him to draw the weapon and
point it in the general direction of the
camera but quote the scene did not call
for the defendant Baldwin to shoot the
Colt revolver
my understanding is that the cult
revolver especially a piece from this
era would be single action not double
action someone commented on this
yesterday which means and actually I
have a single action you have to
actually pull the hammer back before it
can be fired
the question then emerges
if we're assuming this lawsuit is
correct this election is the the
electrician's claims as a witness and
someone involved in the crew is right
maybe he's disgruntled maybe he was a
disgruntled crew member maybe he's lying
I don't know
the first question we have to ask is
why did Alec Baldwin
pull the hammer back on the gun point it
at an individual why weren't there
safety protocols in place why did he
pull the trigger
I think as I stated yesterday we didn't
do a full segment on this which is why I
wanted you know the story came out four
hours ago and I thought it was important
to bring up
we've been giving him the benefit of
Doubt the whole time for no reason I'm
not saying I know what happened I'm
saying the media has protected Alec
Baldwin and framed this whole story so
that from the get-go we assumed it was
an accident they first said it was a
blank they said it was a misfire which
is the wrong terminology they said
shrapnel hit the producer uh the
cinematographer killing her we know all
of that's not true now and this is
witness testimony granted this guy suing
but it's still someone who was on the
crew who's making a statement and saying
this is what happened and what was
supposed to happen
in which case the facts we have to start
Alec Baldwin drew a gun pulled the
hammer back pointed it at the
cinematographer at the camera with a
cinematographer standing there
fired the gun with a live bullet in it
in order to assume that was an accident
we'd have to make a a ton of assumptions
he was mad he had motive
sounds like it right so no those are
also more assumptions however in the
absence of evidence the the solution
that makes the least amount of least
amount of assumptions tends to be the
correct one not that we know
definitively not that we can say for
sure but I'm just pointing out it is
logically absurd to begin the the uh the
story as if we believe it was a mistake
well what's very clear is that Alec
Baldwin has a very skilled team of PR
people that has been rolling this out
bit by bit manipulating The Narrative
seeding things in our mind much the way
a uh you know interrogator will get you
to say Yes And Lead You places plant
things out there uh very uh concerted
effort which you know even if it were an
accident they would do the same thing
right if it was brilliant the total
accident he would definitely hire a
crisis management team they would
definitely be doing everything that
they're doing uh but the the way that
things are coming out bit by bit by bit
now and when you really put it like that
you know he pulls back pulls back to
action points it at the guy pulls shoot
why so so here and doesn't he have a
history of like going off on people back
yeah remember he just attacked the guy
in New York over a parking space the
armor I think she was claiming that uh
she was afraid that people were afraid
of Alec on set basically like if they
were like hey it's too dangerous you
can't do that the Alec would flip his
lid and fire the person he leaves some
nasty voicemail for his own daughter or
daughter calling her the worst names in
the world and being an absolute just Mom
he's trash dude do you remember uh did
you see the video of him and his wife
they got out of the car they were
getting chased by like Paparazzi they
got out of the car to talk to him was
like last week There's video of it and
he's like she was my friend
and then he realized like I didn't say
it with enough emotion I gotta repeat
myself she was my friend but he's such
an actor like yeah most actors go crazy
let me look we got this from YouTube
today Alec Baldwin suesman who accused
actor of punching him over a parking
spot in New York he sues the guy so so
so everyone thought that Tim was crazy
when Tim came up with this idea that
it's possible this wasn't an accident
right but I was like it's not even me
coming up with an idea it's me saying
why are you making assumptions this was
an accident I know we all know that Alec
Baldwin is a huge jerk and he always has
been so there's no reason to assume that
this was an accident there's no reason
to assume that there's no right what
what Grace has he built up what benefit
of the doubt has he built up he is he is
the equivalent of the n-word guy at the
gas station at this point dude from the
beginning everyone was like we have to
be nice to Alec Baldwin this must be
very hard for him I was like do you
think for one single second that if this
were to happen to someone for example
like James Woods that he would be
passionate and graceful he would be on
Twitter before the body was cold
complaining about gun laws he would be
talking about this he went
trick-or-treating afterwards and was
taking you know selfies and photos of
dressed up as a costume I pulled up the
video of the parking lot incident and it
shows Alec he like shoves the guy in the
shoulder so he says it disproves the
claim that you know he punched him this
is going back to 2018. I think it's
still it's still an important point to
make that Alec Baldwin is a hot head yes
like Ian was pointing out people were
scared of him on the set right people
had complained about what was going on
and I think we could even ignore all of
that and just take some basic facts a
woman died
how did she die
she was shot we'll just we're gonna
we're gonna walk backwards she was shot
yep how did she get shot an individual
fired a gun at her yep the individual
was armed with what I believe was a
single action revolver
likely 45 caliber because it's it's a
western
he pointed the gun at her pulled the
hammer back pulled the trigger okay why
did he do it
well according to one witness the scene
did not call for him to actually pull
the hammer back and pull the trigger but
he did anyway yeah so then why would he
have pulled the you know pull the
trigger well then we start getting into
the crew disputes the hot-headedness of
the character I don't understand why
it's logical in any capacity to say he
accidentally pulled a live firearm with
a bullet pulled the hammer back and shot
a woman and be like but let's figure out
how many how we can justify it as an
accident no you made a good point about
crisis management this dude's very
wealthy
very likely his PR firm immediately as
soon as it happened started saying we
need stories saying this they probably
seated false information it was a
misfire as a blank why to create The
Narrative of an accident first and we
walked into that the first thing we said
was it was an accident then we learned
there was a live bullet we said wow how
did that happen that's a crazy accident
and then and then I stopped and thought
to my thought to myself
so I have to assume a woman an armorer
who's trained with Firearms accidentally
loaded a live round gave it to an
assistant director who didn't check it
but claimed it was cold gave it to Alec
Baldwin who wasn't supposed to pull the
trigger who then pulls the trigger and
all of that is true for me to continue
the accident narrative okay I dude I
don't like Alec Baldwin even though he's
just a tremendous actor which just
bothers me him and Glenn Cleary Glenn
Ross is like one of the most powerful
scenes in film oh man it's a good movie
so good uh but the alternative I'm just
playing Devil's Advocate all you a-holes
out there and they're gonna say that I'm
Alec Baldwin they love you in the
comments section by the way no they hate
me in the comment section and there's
like there's bots in there running on me
Chris quit reading comments I love the
comments I love you guys you guys are
incredible I'm all the alternative is is
what that Alec ball he came up with a
way to murder this woman no no no no no
no no no no that's too many assumptions
it's simple hot-headed Alec Baldwin shot
a woman that's it so I think someone put
the bullet in the gun sabotage it's just
an assumption but it's like if I have to
make one
it's gonna be that way they've they've
made that I don't have to make one crew
members have argued his intentional
sabotage and Alec Baldwin's part however
if I'm going to make the least amount of
assumptions it's Alec Baldwin shot and
killed the woman well for sure that's
truth that's not even an assumption
right that's a fact the hammer pointed
the gun and pulled the trigger motive is
this is a guy who's known to be a
hothead who who screamed at his own
daughter who shoved a guy over a parking
space I'm not trying to argue that he's
a rage-filled monster but that he has a
hot he has a temper
so if we're going to look at how this
woman died
do I assume the armorer who's trained in
Firearms accidentally loaded a live
bullet then gave it to a second person
who claimed to have checked it but
didn't who gave it to Alec Baldwin who
is trained for decades with Firearms who
didn't check it or do I say there was a
producer dispute with the crew over the
conditions on the set and then the guy
who's running one of the producers
shoots a woman
why would we so there's a lot of things
that are very difficult to believe in
each of these scenarios they're all
incredible like wow how are any they're
doing live target practice on the set
they're probably getting Hammer the
night before coming in all wasted
doing the armor this but why would you
assume that she said she's 24 she's like
I'm not comfortable in this job I'm
doing two just she was doing two jobs at
once on the set but it's like you can't
say it to Alec because he'll fire you on
the spot I think it's crazy to be to to
assume that the one person who was not
treating the gun properly was the one
person whose job it is to treat the gun
properly you know what I mean right the
armorer is the expert on set why would I
assume she made the mistake and kill and
resulted in a person dying instead of
Alec Baldwin who pulled the trick so you
think you think that she handed uh over
a gun that had a blank in it and Alec
Baldwin inserted a live round in between
receiving the handgun and discharging it
if we're going to start with all of the
facts laid in front of us
it is I in my opinion slightly more
probable that Alec Baldwin loaded the
gun shot than some big gruntal crew
member that walked off
so the crew member is there a chain of
of possession the armorer Hannah
Gutierrez do they have to sign for it
and stuff I don't know yeah right so
I'm not saying it's a it's it's likely
I'm not saying it's true I'm just saying
why would I assume the armorer made a
mistake the assistant director failed to
check it and then Alec Baldwin for no
reason pulled the trigger at a woman and
then add to it very clearly a skilled PR
team is seeding stories manipulating the
media getting we don't know that for
sure it's a big assumption I think it's
likely and fair to say my point is I
don't know I'm so objective it's
annoying sometimes I don't know what
happened I'm just saying that looking at
it for like a mathematical equation
you have this massive tree of like an of
an algorithm like a flow chart of all of
the things that had to happen for this
insane accident to occur and then over
here you have Angry crew Alec Baldwin
hot head shot a woman like it's three
steps it's a guy said I'm angry with the
crew and then shot a woman versus
accident accident accident accident
sabotage conspiracy angry crew and I
just right and we're we're falling into
the Trap of trying to apply rational
thinking to irrational people doing
irrational things and hot-headed people
who have a temper who act out sometimes
now we still don't know it I think we
have to wait until the police
investigation comes out uh if they're
going to even investigate it properly if
a lot of the investigation wasn't
compromised by a lot of his money the
D.A said that they know who put the
bullet in the gun oh wow so maybe you
look yeah we'll see I'm just saying
I feel like a crisis management team
likely was involved in seeding stories
that were clearly false to create the
accident narrative first and then
Prejudice individuals who read on but
now you have a guy who has in a sworn
statement a deposition lawsuit an
established in a lawsuit saying the
scene did not call for him to fire the
gun that is that's big that is big
that's huge as soon as I saw that I was
like this changes a lot and there's a
little bit of motive yeah right there
was disputes there was kind of contested
and so people were quitting they were
walking off set yeah so imagine you've
got hothead Alec Baldwin trying to run a
movie where he's a hothead people like
you know Ian mentioned people were
scared they would get fired hand of
Gutierrez I guess had said that is that
what you were saying uh that's what I
interpolated from the article I was
reading but remember too remember we
were talking about this before the show
it is known in the actor community that
even a blank can kill somebody well yeah
that was the cat that was the cat
don't let him in don't let me don't let
him in yeah
I was always itching when I'm in here uh
we it's known in the actor community and
Alec was an actor then a a young actor
put a blank to his head and killed
himself by accident thinking it was a
blank and that it wasn't going to kill
him so it's known in Hollywood that
blanks can be lethal that's John Eric
Hexum Hexum and and again Alec Baldwin
has Decades of Action Movie experience
right there was already a witness to a
testified that they worked with Alec
Baldwin and he knows not only standard
gun protocol safety but onset gun safety
and he violated so Alec Baldwin for this
accident to have occurred slipped his
mind standard gun safety slipped his
mind standard protocol pulled the
trigger on a gun that in a scene that
didn't call for it was handed a gun by a
guy who claims to protect it but didn't
by a woman who accidentally put a live
bullet in it and didn't check that's
insane to assume they were apparently
doing live target practice on downtime
on set and then they're like no no
people are denying that they were doing
it at all but they're like dude there's
live ammo all over over the set they
were going out and shooting at cans
between tanks
I don't know we'll see I have a feeling
nothing bad's gonna happen to I wonder
if the shooters got to get charged the
production team has got to get charged
the armor and the assistant director all
need to be charged in this I was reading
legal analysis over basic questions and
it seems like based on the facts we have
that have been released whatever the
claims are involuntary manslaughter is
set the fact that it is standard safety
protocol not to point a weapon at
someone to pull the trigger the fact
that he didn't check when he had the
opportunity to do so means someone died
at his hand it was an accident but he's
responsible involuntary manslaughter I'm
waiting for all the Articles to come out
to say Alec Baldwin's a white
supremacist who's obviously leaning on
his white privilege for having killed
this person who was probably a person
she was a woman so she was definitely a
person of color well no she was
Ukrainian she was yeah as we know the
Coalition for communities of color have
said Slavic people are people of color
that's right so Alec Baldwin killed a
colored person yeah there you go person
of color that's sorry oh you can't say
color person no no my bad it is person
of color sorry all right all right let's
do super chats if you haven't already
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and go to timcast.com become a member
one of the members only segment coming
up later tonight but let's read what
y'all have to say in the super chats
Kevin Robson says don't get Brazen with
me that's right yes someone took the
meme you know the 4chan meme where it's
like if only you knew how bad things
really are they took that and changed
bad to Brazen and put it over the judge
and it said if only you knew how bracing
things really are I thought that was
really good yeah
a lot of people are making uh snarky
comments about what happened in Kenosha
which I can't read but Tucker Carlson
had a really snarky one that's going
viral right now
um you can't read it
out it hits hard so good it's amazing
all right well maybe maybe in the bonus
after in the after show oh my gosh all
right Mick G says hey Tim can you give
more insight on the fact Checker
non-profit what's needed for the
position I deal with language and social
media will you have a meet and greet in
Austin I'm just down the road uh we
didn't really plan to do an event in
Austin but our plan is once a month
we'll we're gonna have the mobile studio
in different cities for different events
and then Friday night we'll do a live
venue performance or show so basically
we'll set up a studio on a stage
somewhere and then do timcast IRL Friday
night with a live audience nice yeah
it's gonna be fun so that's the goal
we're not doing it for Austin but as for
the non-profit one of the big challenges
with forming a non-profit is that we did
at the end of the year which means that
we're still awaiting approval from the
IRS for tax exempt status the entities
exist we have the uh the truth and media
foundation and we have the on network or
the on Foundation sorry which is
technology
I've talked to some potential donors who
want to help fund the nonprofits in
their mission but they're like if I
donate now it's not tax deductible until
next month so we basically have to wait
about a month and a half January 1st we
can then take donations start hiring and
things like that so that's probably when
things will kick off as for the job it
is required that you know how to do
research
and we're probably going to have I think
three people start at the nonprofit the
goal is to issue ratings on news
organizations and also issue General
facts checks so we'll have a consistent
like here's fact checks we're going to
apply through pointer for Facebook
status and all that stuff like normal
and we're going to fact check anybody
we'll fact check Snopes yes what we're
going to do is something unique that
people don't do it's called frame
checking did this organization omit key
context in their fact check or their
news assessment CNN for instance in the
story about Kyle Rittenhouse would get a
strike saying falsely framed in the full
testimony here's what was said CNN has
created a false frame what are you going
to do when the nonprofit you start to
turn on you like the intercepted
it's only going to be like three
employees though yeah and it's it's
simple I'll fire them yeah the thing
about The Intercept was that Glenn got
investment and didn't have full control
over the company so when they went off
the rails he was like I guess I have no
choice but to quit for this it's going
to be like three people and if someone
starts violating journalistic ethics
we'll just be like you aren't violating
journalistic ethics you're fired gotcha
yeah so we'll see you know we'll see how
things go Raymond g Stanley Junior says
happy Marine Corps Birthday to all my
fellow brother and sister Devil Dogs out
there may we all find the clearing at
the end of the path Semper Fi right on
oh this is a good bandana companion says
hey Tim did you know that YouTube is
taking out the dislike counter on videos
yes and it's and it's obviously just for
Joe Biden and Dr fauci whose uh
documentary had a I think 128
000 dislikes here's what's gonna happen
all that's gonna happen is people are
gonna be like this video has a million
views and only 10 likes
which clearly means it's ratioed right
they're not doing anything by getting
rid of the dislike button this is stupid
and it clearly only impacts like Biden
and fauci and major corporations that
try to chill on major bull crap by being
disingenuous
and but what are they going to disable
its impact on the log on the algorithm
now that's the question no it's still
going to be there they said it'll you'll
I think you can still see it in the back
end so on your videos you can see it but
this is so pointless creators could
disable that feature if they want to
disable it so this whole ruse that it's
for people's protection is nonsense can
you disable just one of the lights just
the down like I think it's the like and
the dislike altogether you could you
could totally get rid of here's a we
have a really important uh super chat
but I can't read Cyrillic so I'm going
to pretend that the Cyrillic is English
and it says
backwards and backwards n
uh anik
a pub I can't read Cyrillic whatever uh
they said about pinch to zoom even
simple linear interpolation can create
false details in an image but Apple
doesn't use Simple interpolation they've
got machine learning support in Hardware
in 2017. see apple neural engine and it
can do weird things just Google Obama D
pixel there are people posting images of
how zooming in on like iPhones or
whatever can make your image warp and
look really weird so the defense in the
writtenhouse case said
the prosecutor tried to bring in
evidence by zooming in on an iPad and he
says no no they use he said AI 3D
logarithms
in which I should not have made fun of
the Boomer guy for not understanding
what he was talking about but uh uh he
pointed that out and then the judge I
think agreed and said bring in an expert
to prove that's not happening and I'll
allow it and they were like how are we
supposed to do that and the judge was
like you can't admit evidence unless you
can prove it's like real evidence uh the
rokata law uh crew when they were
streaming said the the fact that they
would try and zoom in in real time
instead of zooming in first then giving
it to a forensic uh you know a forensic
expert and then admitting it as evidence
is absurd that's what they should they
should do you shouldn't zoom in in
during court you should take it home
zoom in print it submit it for evidence
to be approved and then have the zoomed
in image right you keep handing the
phone and it's locked and he's like oh
God I got it right now I gotta redo my
passcode a lot of people saying happy
birthday to the Marines so I'll just
shut that out one more time happy
birthday
um Alex barturan asks about yesterday's
IRL episode I will simply say if an
episode does not appear on YouTube it
will be on Rumble yeah so there's
there's you know obvious reasons that
happens but sometimes uh you know we've
got to put stuff up on Rumble that's
right strangely a lot of our our biggest
podcast ever was uh Darren Beatty and it
was it was one that we put on Rumble got
millions of views I think I think it's
also there's an opportunity there
because uh Rumble is a core
um audience it's very active individuals
so if there's a you know a prominent
podcast everyone on Rumble will watch it
so there's there's benefits to when when
we put it up on Rumble revolver drives
big traffic too yeah right so when you
know he's posting the the video too we
definitely get traffic
Trey Marx says Drew Hernandez is
Apparently one of the next people
testifying so there's another eyewitness
account of the attacks on Kyle and I
will I will just say I won't get into
too many details but Drew Hernandez is a
strong-minded individual he's going to
have a clear memory he's going to know
the details and he's going to be
confident in his assessment he'll take
No Nonsense No Nonsense so when the when
the prosecution tries to play
manipulative games I don't think that'll
work on someone like Drew Hernandez
who's going to be of sound mind and
mental fortitude to explain here's what
I saw here's what happened and then when
they try and say but don't you think no
here's what I saw hear what happened but
isn't it possible no here's what I saw
here like Richie McGinnis did oh it's
awesome yeah when he was like everything
you're saying is guesswork and then
Richie goes well he said f you and then
reach for the gun that was amazing like
I I it's not about whether
um Kyle's right or wrong it's about you
know in this instance I'm referring to
journalists who know what they saw know
what they have to say and will not be
manipulated by prosecutors or defense
and you know I I was just listening to
the interview I did with Richie and BG
on the scene about all this I did it
with them earlier this summer and uh or
gosh last year I can't remember now uh
and he uh he said very clearly that he
couldn't he wasn't going to give any
opinions as to motive uh when he was
talking to me and that he was going to
be a witness in the case and all he was
there to do was to give testimony as to
what happened factually and Richie has
held true to that from then all the way
through all the way up until that moment
right there on the stand right so kudos
to you Richie McGinnis man awesome I
posted a funny video people were saying
it was a flex but I thought it was I was
you know poking fun at YouTube so I
guess Crowder shot up his his gold
plaque or whatever
did he do that yeah he did we were just
talking about that so I put up a video
talking about that oh yeah I put up a
video where the the window over there
would not stay open right and I was I
legit was like trying to open the window
to get some circulation because we're
getting work done in the AC unit the
ventilation was shut off and it wouldn't
stay open and I looked over and I saw I
have a golden play button you know you
get when you get a million subscribers
and so the point is I was disrespecting
it not that I was flexing that I'm
disrespecting YouTube so I was like oh
here we go and I prop it in the window
to keep the window open
I thought that was the some people were
like look at that he's flexing like he's
got this gold no no no I'm disrespecting
it it's in the window
it's perfect
uh I mean we have one on the walls
whatever well because there's more than
one Tim that's true there's four correct
yeah there are there are four of them
actually we have like eight I think we
got more videos I won't put it on the
wall till we get the two million
subscribers so hit subscribe yes yeah
Ian Ian is a man of principle he said
it's not fair that he would get this
because he joined the show and we had
like what 300 I don't know no I don't
think I think we had like four it was
later it was like above 500k seven eight
I thought it would we have to check the
tape when whenever we hit a milestone a
million plus that number how many Subs
you think you had in February when I
came on first guessed the first guest oh
did we have like no we had like a
hundred and eighty already yeah like a
hundred thousand because the channel
already had 70 before as soon as we
started that's right because I tweeted I
was like tweeting it I was posting it on
on YouTube because I had other videos on
it and then within like a month we had
like 100. it was just you and me that
day yeah yeah that was just you and me
so we the show has evolved now we got
now Luke's here it really picked up
steam in like August August to November
of 2020.
it got hot and it was like four months
it was September was a massive increase
October was huge and then November was
uh October to November was the biggest I
was here even for the millionth
subscribers yeah we were we were getting
like 150 000 concurrents during the
election I mean it was crazy I remember
yeah
everybody appreciate you watching man
yeah was it the New Year's Eve party or
did we have uh election party that was
incredible we should do that again that
was really fun yeah during the midterms
we should yeah
what we did during the election day was
we had a road we had so many people here
and people just come in and take a seat
Seamus was running things for us okay he
took he took the steering wheel didn't
let go either I gotta rate this one it's
good as snork says been watching for so
long I missed the old stream starting
Jeff I finally got to donate I also got
got a step on snack shirt which I can't
wait to get as a gay furry I feel very
isolated in my political views this is a
great place to relax and feel sane lol
and you know what I want to read that
because I I don't I don't care who you
are what you believe how you want to
live whatever we're trying to just be
honest in our assessment and not be
um
not judge people who want to live the
way they want to live I mean that's what
that's why I think it's crazy that they
say that we're conservative and I think
it's a political tactic because we're
actually fairly Progressive on social
issues we are just not as far left as
they are not everybody I know Lydia's
conservative yeah I'm definitely not but
but this is like a mixed bag of I mean
like you know one of the things you
pointed out is that one of the things
that allowed you to become to vote
Republican was that Republicans opened
up to gay marriage that's right so
that's you know uh in in a traditional
sense for this country that's actually
kind of progressive yeah on social
issues so we're not staunch
conservatives in that regard of closely
libertarian of course that would be the
issue that got jacked I don't know I
don't understand your insinuation I mean
no it's great that's awesome you know
because Jack believes in Liberty in
individuals right to choose and yeah I'm
just saying great job you know that's
that's causing really good I can't I
can't wait for the special that we do
for me and Luke box
in January in January we're probably
going to Nashville in March we're
probably going to Florida but in
February we don't got any plans how
about we take the you know we take the
trailer out to like freedomastan and set
up a a boxing arena but if you lose you
got to get a tattoo that says I love Lou
kardowski on yourself somewhere on your
body
there should be some odds for sure you
know but uh we're not in the same weight
limit first of all but that doesn't suck
I don't know it looks pretty close
let's read some more Super chats let's
read some more all right Kevin Brady
says two things watched the trial and
the coverage of this is gross and I
don't see anything getting better I sent
you an email regarding a cult
documentary for up here in Washington
state I'm a filmmaker oh interesting
well I'll I will take a I will look for
it it's very refreshing to talk about
the case here and to know that there's
so many thousands of people uh listening
because it's actually this is a good we
want to give more than MSNBC yeah like
legitimate coverage to this court case I
think
it's it's remarkable to me you know I
see the news about MSNBC losing Brian
Williams their bleeding talents you know
Brian stelter is going like wow what's
happening and I'm just like maybe
regular people can only be lied to so
many times that's true I think what's
happening with the uh moms who are being
called racists they're probably sitting
around their dining room table also
being like I'm hoping
uh man you know they're calling me
racist I want I wonder if all those
other people they've been calling
racists aren't actually racist too some
someone someone tweeted a good point I
remember who it was but maybe it was you
I don't know they said it's going to be
a major red pill when people who have
been following the writtenhouse trial
see how the news covered it maybe it was
Ian miles strong but there's probably a
lot of regular people who see them see
you know um uh there have been a few
channels that have been playing it like
ABC 7 Chicago is going to live stream on
YouTube there's probably a lot of people
who are interested and they're watching
the trial I mean it is it is interesting
for a lot of people to understand what's
going on and then they read CNN and go
what
I was talking to Steve Hilton last night
on the way down here and I was like you
know most of the people who changed
their mind about Trump did so because
they watched one of his speeches not
commentary about his speech just one of
his speeches so watching this trial I
think is going to be like a red pill
dispensary as well it'd be great Luke's
over there laughing you reading the
comments dude yeah
oh God I think there was a really great
comment by Cassandra Fairbanks she
tweeted that at first she thought it was
a really bad idea for them to put Kyle
redness on the stand yeah but then she
saw him breaking down and she thought to
herself you know something like get this
baby off the stand as a mother like
watching him be attacked and he's just a
young guy so maybe maybe that's what
their goal was really
the reason uh people were criticizing
the defense for not objecting to the
badgering from the prosecution but I
think maybe the goal was we get him to
testify and he does a good job but he
also breaks down and and he shows his
humility and his fear and remorse and
yeah but yeah but the guys on the other
side they all took that as him being uh
you know just afraid that he's going to
jail because he's admitting you know
being on the on the stand and it's
becoming clear that he committed murder
but I want to just point on one thing
real quick my point here is not that the
you know they're going to convince the
left yeah it's that the jury who
supposedly has limited information on
this what are they going to see a guy
crying not necessarily perfect because
he may be crying because he might go to
jail right like you said however the
prosecution then Badgers him and so the
jury sees an annoying prosecution that's
wasting their time by asking the same
question a million times and they see a
defense compassionately you know
speaking with a defendant who's
traumatized yeah uh Joe Kent the uh
Congressional candidate from Washington
State uh he had a very nice tweet today
where he said that uh as a guy who's
been in combat uh him uh and his wife
who was killed in combat uh he said that
everyone reacts differently to re
remembering instances in which you were
forced to kill somebody or experiencing
this kind of trauma and uh I was just
really pleased to see Joe put out such a
empathetic leadership to kind of tweet
like that saying that like emotions and
and Trauma and people react to that in
different ways and we should respect the
way that Kyle is reacting to that
because irrespective of his motive
killing somebody is got is got to be
horrible and we should also give that to
Alec Baldwin hmm yeah but he's an ass
no I agree I completely 100 agree my my
thing about Alec Baldwin is just we
should be wait but have we seen him
break down and cry and remorse that was
the first image from L.A times as him
crying on the phone I don't know if he
was crying but he's like distraught very
much so yeah what I'm trying to say is I
approach the retina's case by looking at
talking to the witnesses literally first
I watched the video we bring the
Witnesses in and we try to the best of
our ability to know the facts what I'm
saying with Alec Baldwin is we must do
the same thing and if the initial
reports of a blank misfiring and
shrapnel hitting a person are not true
we need to erase from our minds our
prejudice assuming there was an accident
and start with the with the core facts
and then work our way back from how it
happened I'm not saying he's guilty I'm
not saying there's proof they did
anything wrong I'm saying just that it's
absurd for us to assume it was an
accident
we don't have any reason to believe that
we just have a story about a guy who
pulled out a gun we should honor the
victim by being open to what the facts
in the court says but the D.A says they
know who put the bullet in there more
soon
um that that makes me feel like it was
not that has been Alec been arrested
I don't know but he was instructed not
to talk about it by the police he said
well if they know who put the bullet in
there and Alec Baldwin hasn't been
arrested can you make that connection
that it's not him no because he's high
profile and famous and they know it
would cause a very big uproar and in
fact if they knew with a bullet in there
and it was a crew member the crew member
would be arrested instantly the fact in
fact I would argue that no crew member
has been arrested when the D.A says they
know who did it oh so suggested it was
Alec Baldwin interesting yeah
that's why I'm saying like we shouldn't
make assumptions about the case though
there are assumptions there as well
which is I try to make the I try to make
the least amount yeah and we are and we
all were influenced by the initial
stories that's why we're even having
this conversation so just be ever
vigilant
yeah man
all right trash Panda says this trial
proves to me that we need a national
divorce we cannot peacefully exist next
to people like bicep guy or the
prosecutor National divorce now before
it's too late it's a it's a scary
Prospect but uh I understand why more
and more people keep saying it and it's
not a right-wing thing John podesta
Boston Globe reported this that he said
the West Coast should secede from the
union if Trump wins the election podesta
is a global hack he's he's like the
military-industrial complex absolute but
he's he works on the Clinton campaign he
worked on the Clinton campaign he's a
high-profile Democratic operative my
point is only to say that there are
democratic establishment actors who are
calling for the dissolution of the
United States yeah CCP is doing that too
absolutely and that's why I think it's a
bad idea
because China comes in and you know I
say it's a bad idea on the global scale
I do think there's a problem when you
have leftists who don't care about the
truth and wants want suffering
they can say whatever they want all day
and night about Q people being dumb but
when they're like I want someone to go
to prison for the sake of me feeling
good as a winner I'm like yo that's evil
it's this balance of like having a free
society that gives freedom to people
that would do the society harm and so
then they become more authoritarian to
protect Society from those people and
then start protecting it from other
people that maybe aren't dangerous I
think dividing it might be the way to
cause least amount of harm if you want
harm reduction you got to have some kind
of civil divorce yeah mutual defense
packed sure but I mean I was talking
about it for years
it's needed all right let's read some
more we got John Hutto says The Young
Turks has subs but not views five
million Subs 40 000 views on 24-hour old
stories their subs left the platform for
Reddit and Twitter in 2012 how much
money have they blown on staff and
Studio
I think a big a big factor is as we
mentioned The Young Turks CNN MSNBC you
know you know Tucker Carlson used to be
on MSNBC
Crossfire right no no no no
it was eponymous show I I don't know if
it was eponymous but he was a host on
MSNBC yeah but he hosted a crossfire
type it was great he did he was he was
one of the main guys on I think with CNN
but he was also he had a show at MSNBC
he got fired here here's what I think
happened to The Young Turks why is it
that they have five million Subs but
they're only getting 40 000 views in
their videos the subs are from a long
time ago people subscribe to The Young
Turks and then over time as The Young
Turks drifted further and further left
many of these people said I don't care
to watch that video anymore not
intentionally not like I hate The Young
Turks but very simply if Chen yuger puts
up a video saying War bad you know
establishment bad someone clicks that I
like this video over time they start
putting up more videos saying
establishment good people will say I'm
not going to click that video they get
less use but those people already
subscribed to the channel
so you look at like a Crowder for
instance and he's got I think five
million but he gets like a million which
makes sense right and then we get we get
like 80 to 100K on clips from this show
with a million Subs The Young Turks have
five times the subs but you know a third
of the viewership
I think that's simply because they've
been around for a long time and they've
churned a large portion of Their
audience and I'm not saying it to be
disrespectful I just think over time the
rest of it's been disrespectful forget
that I think I subscribed to them in
2007. you're probably still subscribed
I'm checking now it's yeah slow internet
not only that but YouTube props them up
oh yeah they do very much
all right let's see what we got
Johnny Knoxville oh really Johnny hey
how's it going says Ayanna Presley got a
hundred thousand retweets calling
writtenhouse a white supremacist
defamation white supremacist is an
opinion and not an actionable statement
unfortunately if she said that he went
to a white supremacist rally then
well maybe because she could argue that
a rally of right Wingers is white
supremacist that's her opinion if she
said it was like a clan rally something
proper and specific then you could be
like I never did that so that Biden
tweet where he shows Kyle or is that
doctored I don't know about that but let
me clarify when I was saying if if they
said he went to a white supremacist
rally and he never went to a rally then
it's libelous because he didn't take an
action if he went to a trump rally and
she said white supremacist rally it's
not actionable because it's their
opinion Nazi is in fact an opinion as
well like if you if I've talked to a
bunch of lawyers about this and they're
like everybody knows the word is rather
meaningless everyone calls everybody a
Nazi or a fascist so it's not actionable
so you can but today but like say five
six eight years ago I had much different
impact if they say if if someone said
like person acts as a card-carrying
member of the Nazi party then you could
be like that's defamatory and not true
the problem that is you still need
damages so it is not easy not not easy
all right let's grab some more Super
chats what do we got
James week says I agree with the judge
better 10 guilty men go free than one
innocent be punished Ada Binger and the
mainstream media are the guilty ones
walking free that's right they they are
bad bad people the prosecutor is a bad
dude
you know I I just
he sarnovich tweeted out this guy knew
he's gotten away with us in the past and
he wasn't you know ready for a real
judge you look at what this guy does and
it is just outright disdain and
disrespect for our values for our system
and this is what I was saying before the
problem is this guy violates the
Constitution
overtly and the judge says but I want to
preserve this this legal system and I'm
like then you allow the liars cheaters
deceivers the Stealers to keep
destroying the system I I think uh a
Justified mistrial would be something
society would be very good for society
in modern day
I don't normally read crypto posts but
this one I must
Jackson H says while the rest of the
crypto Market is tanking the fjb token
just pumped over 300 today and the
founder donated another 10K to military
Charities wow don't miss out on the ride
Tim Jack I know you want to let's go
Brandon uh I'm not gonna buy fjb token
but I just think it's hilarious 300 last
night so that's what they're saying is
it's hanking Bitcoin down three percent
ethereum down two percent yeah no
crypto's been through the roof it's
insane yeah because I gotta talk about
tanking I think he's making a joke oh I
see the FJ because as soon as he said
that I pulled out my phone I was like
wait really what's going on there's
there's also the time to buy there's
let's go Brandon token and fjb token
because making tokens takes five minutes
gotcha but I I I'll tell you this I
don't care for useless tokens where they
just try and sell them but if someone
said they were making a token with the
express purpose of fundraising for a
charity meaning you buy the tokens and
the proceeds from the organization that
released them uses that to fund you know
military Charities like they did well
that's fantastic
basically that just means buying the
token is a donation some people are
trying to speculate maybe get rich off
of it but it means that the core
organization can be helping out I like
the idea I don't know if that counts as
a security I don't think so all right
Trinidad of pressure batacav care says
please get Rakata on timcast and teach
him how to say my name huh why because
you can't say true and Anana I'll go
slow shruin and Nana Shabba depressure
bada kaf care very simple I sat there
listening to it on Luke and transcribing
it I slowed it down hit shifted it
truing a non-reshable to pressure
and then I wrote it out profound yes
yeah because people were saying true and
elizola Bishop her pressure or something
like that and I was like you guys didn't
even try them retweet it without comment
s i don't even speak proper English so
I'm impressed that's great
all right let's see
rompot
mechanico says Tim can you look into
evergrand second largest real estate
developer in China defaulted on its
bonds today in the amount of 100 148
million I heard this I've been tracking
it passively the story about evergrand
this could be could precipitate a major
collapse in the global markets China's
phony real estate
yeah man we'll see
everyone in finance markets have known
that the Chinese debt industry and all
that has been overblown for decades I
worked at a private Equity Firm on a
hedge fund uh in 98 9 2000 2001 and even
then every comment about China which is
all lie all lie all fabricated nobody's
trusted anything that's come out of
there forever
why would you which is why why did we
trust any of those videos that were
coming out from Wuhan in November and
December of people falling over and
stories of like billions of cell phones
being taken off long that's weird right
yeah so like that was you know people
believed that yep and the nation bought
that bats peeing on people I mean this
is all Chinese man well let's uh South
Park really nailed the origins let's get
uh we'll do two more two more quick ones
we got Andrew suttony says Alec Baldwin
is a Top Gun actor so I suppose he was
in Top Gun I don't know I'm not sure no
he wasn't right and that was wrong I
don't think so and then
dauber says the armor was inexperienced
and has made mistakes before she only
had the job because her father was the
lead prop master I did hear that
interesting point
however
this means that the armor made a mistake
handed it to another person who made a
mistake who handed it to another person
who made a mistake who then shot a woman
I mean that's just a big that's many
leaps you know what I mean so maybe it's
possible sometimes people win the
lottery you get the numbers they line up
and it's astronomical odds we went to
the casino a couple weeks ago you put
you know 20 bucks on 26 and then you
know we ended up winning a bunch of
money because sometimes 26 comes out and
if there's an ethos of people not taking
precautions on the set if that's the
production company's method then you're
gonna get five and six people not take
precautions all at once that's possible
all right everybody smash that like
button if you haven't already done so
subscribe to this channel take that URL
post it everywhere if every single
person took the URL right now and just
posted on all their social media we
would be bigger than CNN overnight but I
guess some people don't and you don't
have to we just appreciate it if you did
but go to timcast.com and become a
member with a massive Library you can
search through all of the different
guests we've had for these members on
the segments and we will have a members
only segment coming up posted on around
11 or so PM you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast check out my Instagram follow
me there and uh Jack you got anything
shout out uh I definitely do you can
follow me on Twitter at Jack Murphy live
in fact all over the Internet Instagram
everywhere Jack Murphy live uh also
check out jackbrunch.com we're coming to
the San Francisco area in two weeks we
were just in Austin beautiful city we
had about 90 people come out for brunch
it was fantastic people leave feeling
joyful and uplifted they make new
friends and it's just a really cool
experience to be around 100 people that
see the world the same way that you do
know this know the same media people
speak the same language and are going to
view events through a similar filter
it's a lot of fun and uh you guys should
come down check it out right on maybe
one day if you're subscribed to look
uncensored.com don't forget to check out
today's video I had a very interesting
conversation about the occult demonic
forces Satanism all of that is available
on Luke uncensored.com hope to see some
you guys there thanks for having me
um also ecstatic that you guys are back
and I'm happy to be here my name is Ian
Crossland check me out on social media
if you'd like to and I'll see you later
I am sour patchless and I do want to say
that I do love my crayon eaters in the
Marines so happy birthday to the Marine
Corps my brother was a marine and I have
deep respect they are badasses so
definitely shout out to them you guys
can follow me on Twitter at sour
patchlands we will see all of you over
at timcast.com in the member segment
thanks for hanging out bye guys